so i see this
story a woman was told to wear a mask
so she takes the baton from the sheriff
starts beating the crap out of the
sheriff
and i thought to myself man that's
really crazy especially because we've
seen a lot of instances now
of people refusing to abide by lockdown
or
you know sticking it to the man i guess
like there's one video where a guy parks
his truck behind the health inspector
and he's like if i can't work you can't
work either
and the cop is like you got to move your
truck straight i'm not moving anything
i'm desperate i'm not doing anything
and so we're seeing stuff like this so i
see this story about this this cop
getting beaten i'm like man that's
that's crazy
because it's one thing to say you're not
going to wear a mask and then everyone
makes a viral video about you
it's another thing to say you're going
to keep your business open and you get
arrested it's another thing to be some
lady going to the gas stations and
beating the cop with their own baton
now that's a step over the line that's
where you know people are starting to
snap
so we're looking up these stories like
oh let's let's see you know let's see
what's
is there is there a bigger story here
you just google search it
we got like i think four stories already
very very similar
some some navy vet bashed a guy over
that with a bottle
because he was told he had to wear a
mask people aren't having it anymore
and that's kind of freaky but this does
tie into what we're going to see
coming up on january 6 because you got
all these people coming to dc
donald trump says have this big rally
and you got to understand that
the lockdowns are coming almost entirely
from democrats they're definitely our
republicans who are pushing certain
lockdown restrictions and things like
that
but you got a lot of people they got
nothing left to lose
they've lost their business they they've
lost their livelihood
their lives are at risk they got free
time just like we saw with the george
floyd riots people had nothing to do
they were bored their jobs were gone and
they snapped and they went out and they
smashed everything up
now you've got people who are being told
the guy they voted for they like
is not going to win and they got nothing
left to lose so when you start seeing
these stories about people
bashing somebody with a bottle or
beating cops i'm like man things are
starting to get spicy so we'll talk
about that
we've got a bunch of other stories too
the actual big news i guess is that
mitch mcconnell rejected the 2000
stimulus proposed his own bill
that has a provision in it to repeal
section 230 which is causing a huge
debate a lot of trump supporters are
totally for it
i think many people on the internet
including most on the left and many
moderate independent types are against
it
that'll be interesting too and then
probably the greatest and only good
thing to come out of the omnibus bill
is that of all the things they snuck
into this 5
500 page bill was a provision mandating
the pentagon released their information
on ufos in 180 days
and i'm like i'm kind of okay with that
one like the rest of them we can
complain about that one's cool so we're
gonna talk about all this
uh hanging out today uh we got eric july
again hey man how's it going man thanks
for
for sticking around hanging out man i'm
i'm here and i appreciate it again this
was fun it's funny
yesterday we had a great episode that
was good that was good and we had to we
had to do it again because luke wasn't
feeling too well
we had to bring luke back so that we
could have this bigger conversation well
i'm not going to run away this time but
me and eric are going to
again contest a lot of your ideas which
i'm very excited about hopefully
i'm going to moderate uh blood cat
versus but uh yeah i mean we've got a
lot of stuff to debate about taxation
being tough now
exactly but most importantly sorry for
walking out on you amazing human beings
i had a migraine all day and then for
some reason i was at a level where i was
about to puke or pass out
yeah and that's not good for television
so i just kind of walked away
you know you really want to what is it
you forgot to take this uh you forgot
i i'd rather not show everybody
every time we reference it that it's
here because it's hilarious he gets a
shout out yep
that was his trick you know not walking
out today thanks so much for having me
on
yeah right on you pass me that male
vitality are you gonna are you gonna
take some
yeah no no i'm gonna do it i'm gonna
spin it i'm gonna spin the male vitality
oh there we go
we're at it it's everything
a better gorilla with a new and improved
set piece
yeah somehow the gorillas become like a
mascot it looks good in red
it does we've kind of decided you
couldn't really tell what it was in blue
i'll show you
it's a little uh it's so cool amorphous
so i think we'll stick with red for now
it's so cool but eric if you think i
should have changed the color to let me
know
hey where is my favorite color so music
with it i'm glad you're back luke
oh yeah i was sad when you walked out
yesterday are you feeling good you got
your kombucha
yeah just like meditation i feel i feel
like if i would pass out or puke
you would like give me a stink eye and
then be like also in the news
we turn the camera on no we turn
[Music]
i'm also extremely grateful for being
healthy i woke up this morning and i
felt
amazing and again a lot of people take
their health for granted
don't uh seriously i'm extremely happy
to be healthy and cognitive and not in
pain and suffering
uh so seriously uh don't don't take
advantage you don't appreciate the
health thing
you know the easiest way to understand
that sentiment is it's like
you never think about breathing out of
both nostrils until your nose gets
stuffed
and then you can't remember what it was
like you know you're like man remember
what i can't
what was i i didn't even notice
breathing out of both nostrils now my
nose is all stuff that i'm sick and
it's hard to breathe yeah a lot of us
you know don't don't take it seriously
how amazing it is to be healthy there's
so many of us that are not healthy
seriously appreciate it and you gotta
keep working and striving to be your
best
all the time now especially in the sick
and twisted world with so much
crap shoved down your mouth hole
figuratively and literally that you did
you watch the show yesterday last night
afternoon
dude we talked about busting up the
federal reserve
yeah man get it on i like that topic all
right all right all right uh lydia she's
producing i am over the corner pushing
buttons rapidly well let's talk about
uh this crazy story man check this out
it's from the daily mail oh actually
hold on i'm sorry i can't believe i just
did it yeah man what's up smash the like
button subscribe hit the notification
bell okay where was i
dailymail.com moment woman beats
sheriff's deputy with her own baton
after being told she couldn't enter a
gas station without a mask
they say st louis county sheriff's
deputy 59 was working security at a
shell gas station late on christmas day
when she was attacked by a maskless
customer i like how maskless is now like
an identifier
because everybody's wearing masks if
you're not that's that's how they
identify you
mask list officials say the deputy told
the female suspect to put on a mask
which prompted her to attack the officer
with her fists in a parking lot
assault was captured on cell phone video
shot by bystanders
suspect managed to grab deputy's baton
and strike her in the head causing a
concussion
deputy pursued her attacker and fought
back before the woman fled the scene
that's crazy i don't know if they made
an arrest now that deputy
you hear the story and you imagine it's
some like strapping young male cop no it
was a lady and it was a 59 year old
woman she was working security at the
gas station when the woman entered the
store without a face covering
you can see some some of the clips there
and then just
pulls her out of her car i guess the
victim stated the suspect became
belligerent
when the victim informed the suspect the
suspect should not enter the business
without a mask
according to the police surveillance
video from inside the store
shows a suspect putting on a mask then
seemingly exchanging some words of the
deputy standing by the door this is
weird
it's a weird story i wonder if this
actually has anything to do with masks
and more of people just being
you know crazy but then we've got we got
another story let me see if this is it
yeah
bar attack suspect captured charge of
the salt this is from christmas eve
they say the man accused of hitting a
houston bar employee in the head with a
glass
has been arrested houston police chief
art acevedo tweeted thursday
the suspect has been apprehended and
charged with assault now they say this
is a navy veteran who did this
he was charged with assault and it
started uh he was
the guy who got attacked and bashed
without the glass got 10 stitches the
conflict began when the customer did not
want to wear a mask we got a bunch of
stories about this
look at this man arrested for shooting
at gas station after being told to wear
a mask
this from only a couple days ago i just
did a google search and all these
stories started popping up
and then if i just show you google look
at this you got story about like well
this is different
airline kicks off a family because a
toddler wouldn't wear a mask doctor's
license suspended for refusing to wear a
mask
oregon doctor refuses to wear a mask man
arrested for
refusing to wear a mask on a flight from
salt lake city what's this one
still refusing to wear a mask bill nye
would like to have a word with you whoa
i don't want to get on bill nye's bad
side so you're telling me to wear a mask
bill
and and we're all good well from the
first video it looked like both of the
ladies were in the same weight class
and that was a that was a world class
like world star
esque videos
the weight class was obese uh just for
everyone they're just for the record
and you can't see it yeah and i i think
people have had enough i mean there's
more and more instances of individuals
getting into physical confrontations
because of the mask issue just even
this morning there was a video going
around of a disabled us army veteran
getting arrested getting manhandled by a
bunch of police officers because he
allegedly wouldn't wear a mask inside of
a mall
so we're seeing a lot of these
incidences and i think we're going to
see more of them and it's really a pity
because
a lot of individuals are forced to do
this by their states because the state
mandates that if you want to have a
business
you're going to force everyone to wear a
mask in the united kingdom
they're mandating bar owners to stop
people from
singing now i don't know about you i
wouldn't want to be a bar owner trying
to tell drunk british people
because that's a recipe for disaster uh
especially at a bar especially how crazy
people get but we have to remember
all this conflict all of this infighting
a lot of the fights that start with
masks
all revolve around government mandates
and orders and executive orders with not
with government officials not laws
government officials saying you better
tell everyone to wear a mask inside of
your bodega
or are you going to lose your business
license are you going to lose your
liquor license or are you going to lose
whatever license we give you
and you're going to stop being able to
provide for yourself because of this
imaginary made up little rule that we
just made up on the spot
you know what this this really
highlights a funny phenomenon that's
going on right now
you got a lot of young people who you
know 10 years ago weren't involved in
politics and are now in politics and
they're very much like alignment
democrats politically
like a lot of these younger youtubers
and commentators some of whom we've had
here they're younger guys
and they're like there seems to be due
to this inexperience a lack of
understanding
of what libertarian means the fact that
there's left and right libertarians
and that for the most part they're all
very critical of policing and government
regardless of whether you're left or
right and so there's a phony post on
uh it's called leopards ate my face as a
subreddit where they basically talk
about it's like hypocrisy
it's like somebody who advocates for
something then becoming a victim of
something so
an anti-vaxxer saying oh no i got sick
if only there was something i could you
know could have done
but there was a post from our slash
libertarian breaking down what they
don't like about cops and policing
like right now when it pertains to covet
and they were like
ha they're they're reaping what they
have sown and then a bunch of people in
the comments were like i'm pretty sure
libertarians don't like cops
like i'm not i'm not sure like what you
think is going on they've always been
criticizing you know uh
like policing in this in this fashion
what i find really funny about all this
is i posted a comment
when there's that video of the dude who
parks his truck behind the healthcare
worker
and i posted a video saying basically if
the cops were enforcing this
when antifa was destroying businesses i
defended the cops who are protecting
those businesses
now the cops are the ones destroying
these businesses and they're not doing
it under any constitutional law
like are any constitutional authority or
statutory law literally just some
edict some healthcare guys like shut
them down the cop goes you got it
so i criticize it and i see these people
who clearly have no political experience
have not been involved before
they're like no all of a sudden these
people on the right are are angry at
cops and i'm like bro i don't think you
know who i
am like i've i'll criticize people who
are violating the rights of individuals
but we're seeing from this i think it is
fair to say there's a lot of
conservatives who are not waking up to
the fact
absolutely these these cops they're
going to shut you down and i
and i say this out of experience
obviously doing what i do over at the
blaze and having so many conversations
with these guys a lot of folks positions
are changing
much like it is with like the healthcare
industry and nurses and stuff
you're starting to see people on that
side start to alter their position
on on cops which they should i mean if
you extended what they actually
claim to believe with this whole limited
form of government and all those sorts
of things to the logical conclusion then
that's exactly what they
would be i mean who is the one that that
that enforces all of these laws that you
may have an issue with
i always tell them about would it be
taxation and all these other sorts of
things that they will pin on the bernie
sanders of the world the aocs of the
world you can recognize that they
aren't very smart people but it also
isn't them that goes out and enforces
these laws the teeth of the state is
all the police officers and this is why
we call them that it's just gums
at that point it's just they just like
we see that as an example right here
with the executive order where they
could just pull it out of their behind
if the cops said which you have seen in
some local levels not
most places but some instances but
if the cops just said no then that would
be it
it would be nothing to discuss there
would be nothing this is why i'm like
this is an easy thing but unfortunately
it takes a lot of folks that have you
know back the blue types all of them to
actually have to say
the people that we have been protecting
are the folks that are responsible for
the destruction right
it's not just that eric when we talk
about this protection we really have to
look at it from
all the kind of events that have been
unfolding during the summer
right now we have cops that are acting
like tough guys roughing up a disabled
us army veteran
where were they when the black lives
matter was rioting
breaking looting and destroying people's
personal businesses they were there
twiddling their thumbs watching standing
by
fox news had it in new york city where
people were just brazenly breaking into
every store that they wanted police
officers on the same block were just
literally standing there kicking rocks
not doing nothing
so on the backdrop of that are they
really protecting us or they're really
pushing a political agenda
on all of us you know what i got no
problem if the cops aren't going to
protect new york city from itself
i mean my thing is about you know i get
it
i i'm obviously i'm an advocate huge
advocate of private property rights and
it's one thing for them and this is why
i've always said like look
i don't want a new law i don't want to
sit up here and
lecture the cops about what they should
and shouldn't do i don't care for that
how about this allow free people
to put that power more so back in their
own hands
so why can't they protect their own
business essentially illegal there
right so if they we saw that minneapolis
pawn shop owner
guy comes and loots his store he airs
his i almost
said something but he aired him out he
aired him out
he's the one that goes to jail right for
him defending because out there they
have this sort of duty to retreat law
out there so you can't like i could in
texas if you bust into my store i could
shoot you where in some places you
cannot do that
so that's what what makes it a
free-for-all that way
and unfortunately people think the
answer is okay we just need to send
cops to go do this this and this and i'm
like it's less about that
and more about people being free to
let's say protect themselves and their
own property if they had that freedom
they won't be more likely to exercise
like also in st louis with that couple
that walked out
yeah firearms they're the ones that went
to jail they're the ones that were
prosecuted
cops seized their guns yes they were on
their own property
people came in and they said get out the
cops took the guns from them they got
arrested yeah new york city you can't
even have pepper spray
you can't even legally own pepper spray
and then they're going to tell you that
the police officers are protecting and
serving you
i'll say this i do think the laws are
completely overbearing in places like
new york but one of the big problems is
density
so you know uh i'm driving you know
around the middle of nowhere
and i'm wondering why it is like there's
no cops anywhere in these areas you know
i was talking to somebody who mentioned
in in some of these places uh let's say
like west virginia because we've been
looking at property west virginia so
we've been you know kind of driving
around a little bit
they're like there's no cops none and
i'm like why where's the crime at
doesn't somebody like break on your
property and they're like oh look a shot
everybody knows it yeah so you've got
all of these houses in this neighborhood
and i'm like no crime no crime why not
well if anyone goes anywhere near my
house i get shot
everybody knows it you want to walk on
someone's property you knock on the door
politely and they'll come and answer the
door with their shotgun
if you break out of their property start
going through their garage you're gonna
get shot
simple as that but but you know in new
york city i guess the problem is density
everybody stacked on top of each other
like how would that work if if someone
broke in your apartment you shot them
and then bolts are going through
apartments and stuff like that
yeah i mean obviously that's that's that
that's the training portion and
obviously
there's a lot of libertarians out there
trying to get people you only sell
hollow points yeah
right right so you're not actually
shooting five five six uh just
shooting through uh one no but but there
you go you just said gun control
no you only sell well it's called
frangible right when they're pulling
me in a corner here i'm being facetious
but no but for real like you know if
you're if you're out in the middle of
nowhere you can have
like an ar-15 and that might make sense
you got a
massive property let's say you live on
50 acres of small house and you see
someone going through like your barn or
whatever
it might make sense to have a rifle you
can use from far away so you don't have
to encounter whoever this person is it
might be armed it might be dangerous
what if you get reports that there's
armed groups going around a rating
looting places you want a gun that's
going to have decent range to keep you
safe right or
a wild animal or or a bear or something
right but if you're in a small
important apartment in new york city
you're in a concrete box stacked on top
of each other
if you have an ar or you know five five
six or whatever that's gonna that's
gonna go through some walls you know
what i mean
no i mean again as it goes back to the
training the training aspect which is
more
that's just as important we talk about
gun control and all of that sort of
thing like
look i want people to get trained on how
to use their their weaponry i want
people to be able to exercise
uh that particular right de-escalation
is a big thing that i talk
a lot about but unfortunately when it
comes to instances like new york and
those cities definitely those inner
cities
they have been it is literally illegal
for them to defend themselves like it's
illegal for them to do it that's why i
think
it should be illegal in new york city
for police officers to have automatic
weapons
in new york city they have this hit
squad i forgot their exact
name or their or their kind of tag or
origin line but they have these officers
that look like ninja turtles
and they walk around with automatic
machine guns in
new york city um i i forgot exactly the
exact make and model like actual machine
guns are just like select fire
full automatic uh assault not assault
rifles
no no no no no no no no no assault
rifles are legit assault weapon is the
maybe yeah yeah uh you know long barrel
rifles that
are fully automatic and i'm like that's
the
like stupidest weapon you could have in
times square with such a large crowd
especially if you're going to have a lot
of innocent bystanders all around you
and if you look at many of the police
shootings in new york city
even with their uh handguns they
automatically
shoot so many times they're so untrained
that a lot of times innocent bystanders
are hit so here we go
if you're going to ban guns you're
banning guns not
for certain people if new york city says
you can't have these guns then nobody
can have them not even the cops
and that's that's why but that's why
that would never be a thing because
that's not what this is about they
ultimately want that
one institution and even the leftists
who who advocate for gun control i don't
think they understand
to the extent of what it is that they're
advocating right it's like
i don't want these guns to be on the
street and that's that's where the
argument is this is like
i don't want you to have that gun and
they walk away but who's the one that's
gonna enforce it what type of guns do do
they have what if i decide that okay
this isn't up for grabs here
what do you want them to do to me well
when they start answering those
questions as well
they that institution should have better
weapons than you
that institution should be able to kill
you in the event that you
you defend themselves so that's the
thing like why i don't take like
leftists a lot of mainstream leftists
seriously when they talk about police
brutality or or the
or these sorts of uh concepts of gun
control and all of that because at the
end of the day
they would send that same institution to
go whoop
up on someone in the event they needed
to take away their gun well they have
the illusion that government is there to
protect and serve them
it's not yeah sorry so i'm curious man i
wonder if all of this covets stuff is
going to make everybody a lot more
right-wing
well but just to give you an example
like people are forced to leave cities
right
there's this viral post where somebody
was like i don't want to go back to
normal
i don't want the way normal was standing
shoulder to shoulder with people in a
subway cart breathing their their spit
in their sweat
i don't want to walk crowded on
sidewalks unable to even like waiting in
line to get a sandwich
i don't want to go back to normal normal
was awful and they said maybe i should
move to the suburbs
maybe people are now realizing that
being crammed in a
in a a concrete cubicle in a city that
sounds like smells like sour milk
stacked on top of each other isn't so
fun
and kova is making everybody kind of
spread out and move to other areas
and that can be a good thing in the long
run because they're going to start
having to do hard work to survive
and they're going to understand the
value of what they've produced well
whenever we have the changing of the
guard
especially with u.s presidents whenever
it's a republican president
usually the liberals kind of mobilize
themselves and start getting activated
we're going to see something very
similar with
biden and a lot of conservatives and a
lot of people leaning towards
conservatives because biden has that
power he has already promised
a hundred days of masks during his first
days in office
and of course he also appointed dr fauci
to a very prominent position with his
administration
dr fauci by the way just came out
moments ago and said put aside the
nonsense of making masks
be a political statement or not we know
it works
for us do you ever do that exactly they
keep they keep
saying look i got no problem wearing a
mess it's meaningless to me okay
it's annoying sometimes i go to the
store i'll put it on how long am i
really wearing for 10 15 minutes
i leave or take it off the the issue is
we've been wearing masks exactly
doing another mask man it's not going to
change anything and they keep saying
well
this would all be over people would just
wear masks we've been wearing masks
the days there's just there are some
instances where people don't wear it
but what what does that matter you all
went out and we're dancing around for
biden taking your mask off and drinking
champagne it's don't blame these people
it's not only that tim it's the same
people like dr fauci that were telling
you
not to wear a mask oh yeah because it
doesn't help you
the cdc head don't wear a mask the same
dr fauci that was lying to you about her
immunity and all these other issues wow
that was financing the gain of function
research
hold on hold on fouch is lying now yeah
he's lying now
he used to say 60 to 70 hurt immunity
in order for us to be back to normal now
he's saying oh i don't really mean that
i think people are ready to hear the
truth 75 to 85 but hold on
the world health organization says 60 to
70.
so which is it who's lying well youtube
says
we have to abide by the world health
organization guidelines that means
fouchy's a liar
oh yeah what i don't care how many times
brad pitt played him
i'm not going to believe him sorry sorry
guys well not no but
with fauci i mean he's moved the goal
post a million times
um and i just don't understand why
people still are listening to this man
because you know he it's not like he's
been correct necessarily on anything it
is that we do but we hold this guy up to
the
i'm also worship him i don't uh but a
lot of these guys worship him at the
altar and we listen to everything it is
that he's supposed to say never mind the
fact that he's been virtually wrong
like i don't know how many times there's
a there's a viral video showing
everything he's said that's been
contradicted and i'll tell you what it
is
on the left they say he's this great and
honorable you know
genius who's guiding us to safety and
they trust him many people on the right
because i don't
i don't think the right for the most
part is is a monolith in this regard
they say that he's you know crooked
corrupt he's profiting and all that i
don't know hold on
everybody needs a chill fauci i'll tell
you exactly what he does because i read
the news
non-stop all day every day he waits two
days
and then repeats whatever he heard on
from the mainstream media that's why
he's behind the times so i see these
interviews where he's like you don't
need a mask you know you don't
you're going around wearing this and i'm
like he's just repeating the talking
point that came out in the new york
times two days ago
and then as soon as the mask thing is
like oh actually we should wear masks
then two days after the story breaks and
we're given the guidelines he goes
well you really should win um is that it
you just wait for the news to feel safe
about what your opinion is
and then you give your opinion that's
not really an expert giving us an expert
opinion no he's just repeating the news
well
dr fauci has been around for a very long
time he's been advising
many presidents and i think it's very
important to also note that he was the
individual
funding and backing the level for wuhan
laboratory when it came to
risky coronavirus research specifically
gain of function research trying to
figure out how to make a deadly bat
coronavirus
infect human beings that's what he was
doing months
before of course the main coronavirus
it was washington post that actually ran
the op-ed asking the question about the
origins of the virus in this lab it was
the washington post
and i reported on it and they they tried
claiming that i was pushing conspiracies
and i was like oh no no i was criticized
trust me i was saying they're crazy of
course they're crazy i'm the smart one
telling the washington post
i'm saying they're fake news right
they're allowed to report it
and if i say that they say i'm wrong
trump sees a report from tech crunch on
on zpac and h hydroxic chloroquine and
he repeats it he said oh i saw this
story you know
it looks promising and they're like oh
trump's crazy he's lying he's wrong
and i'm like he's just telling you what
he saw in the news man but but listen
listen we got we got all these people
snapping off
they're getting sick and tired of
lockdowns joe biden saying the lockdowns
not going to stop no he's well i'm sorry
he said we're going to listen to the
science and his science advisor says
what do you say six months then we got
bill gates and fauci saying 2022.
now we got this from the guardian the
world health organization
warns covet 19 pandemic is not
necessarily
the big one experts tell end-of-year
media briefing that virus is likely to
become
endemic and the world will have to learn
to live with it
now does that mean that we're all going
to chill out reduce the lockdowns
take some precautions maybe get a
vaccine or does it mean we're locked
down forever
i think it's locked on fire i think well
no i mean they've shown that it
well now when i say it works not that it
actually helps in mitigating whatever
spread it works is
in the fact that they can control you
they know that they can do that that's a
thing that they can do
they can shut everything down um and do
whatever it is that they want and that's
what they were allowed to do so i think
that is what people are going to see as
a new normal because
unfortunately 10 even a decade ago it's
just
unreal could you just imagine someone
being like yeah
there's going to be this virus that it's
like a 99.9 percent survival rate and
we're going to shut
not just this country down but multiple
countries that could you know we're just
going to shut down the small businesses
and allow the big corporate buddies
right well that will
transfer and you can still go out and
dance for biden yeah most well and you
can of course protest
for black lives if that's your thing as
well that's that's also on the table
but no like they they recognize that it
works and the people that are in control
the for whatever reason the people that
we listen to whether they're health
expert or not i mean bill gates i mean
i'm always seeing him on tv lecturing
lecturing us about this uh issue as well
but that's what it is that they won this
is why i say like civil disobedience
man is like i know i got called a
conspiracy theorist
very early on in this pandemic when i
talked about like dude
if you idiots think that it's just going
to be two weeks i'm sorry
we know that there's no such thing as a
temporary government program they're
going to kick the can down the road
again and they still didn't listen
i i i got to stop here and this
misinformation
or i should i shouldn't say
misinformation i should say you know how
dare you
criticize bill gates it is it is a
long-standing tradition in this country
to turn to software developers for their
expertise and epidemiology
now bill gates who who's more qualified
than a talk about a virus
than a guy who made a bunch of computer
programs
computer there's viruses on computers
different viruses there you go
virus same word right
i wonder how many like you know people
who hate me are going to take that out
of context
anyway anyway look here here's here's
the main point with the story though
they're just saying it's going to get
worse right you guys remember that v4
vendetta scene
where the chancellor was like i want
them to know
why they need us and then it shows all
the news clips playing
and there's like the guy in the bar and
he's watching the story and he goes do
you believe this bollocks
and like people are shaking their head
at it so i see these stories where
they're like
kovid we'll keep mutating it will only
get worse and we don't know if the
vaccine is going to help
and now we got we got a couple stories i
want to show you to exemplify this
the first one is is this one from the
new york times
small number of covid patients develop
severe psychotic
symptoms most had no history of mental
illness
and became psychotic weeks after
contracting the virus
cases are expected to remain rare but
are being reported worldwide
all right there's one more story i got
to show you but i got a question for
this when those people got bell's palsy
they said oh but only a few people got
bell's palsy from the vaccine it's not a
big deal
so a couple people get psychotic
symptoms and they think it's it's you
know major new york times publish this
story boom breaking
i see this story and at this point i'm
just like are you kidding me dude
they're saying covet causes blood clots
your your feet scab up
you know you can't breathe infertility
your heart stops and you go psychotic it
does all these things
calm down man if that's true then we're
in serious trouble right but but to be
fair okay maybe it is true that's why
they're all freaking out
okay but it kind of does feel like
they're just inundating with this stuff
and and that's exemplified by this next
story from abc news
nurse tests positive for covid19 shortly
after getting
vaccinated you mean to tell me they get
they get the vaccine
and then eight days later they get sick
and they say the scenario isn't
unexpected
here's how it could have happened but
maybe they already had the virus before
getting the vaccine
but i'll tell you what this story is
more fear i'm sorry the vaccine
that why is abc news telling us the
vaccine that there are
they're putting out the story that
questions whether the vaccine is gonna
work
they want us terrified so that we just
just give in and say
do whatever you want government shut
everything down forever and let people
just wallow in it that's exactly what
they want but i mean
look this is why it was so important
that no matter where you were at on this
issue i mean i understand there was a
lot of people that were freaking out
early on like you didn't know
much about the vice okay let's just say
for the sake of conversation though
the numbers were out coming out of south
korea and even china they said the same
thing
uh believe them or not they they
actually said that's the same thing as
far as who it impacted
how deadly it actually it actually was
but that's why it was so
important there to say no like you had
to do it then because if you didn't do
it then
you showed them you showed the state you
showed the uh whether it be local
governments the governors the
every congress woman and man you showed
them that that's all that it takes is to
scare you
that's all when do they report good news
wouldn't it be fantastic news
for them to say yeah not mo
the vast and when i say vast majority of
people that catch this like it's not
even close like
the vast majority of that catch this
will never have to go to the hospital
and they will never get severely sick
that's not my opinion
their own their own data says most
importantly you brought up a very
important point before saying
that there's too many things going for
the elites for them to stop this
they're benefiting absolutely too much
and then also when you look at v for
vendetta it is
eerily eerily very similar to what's
happening right now and just to remind
you and v for vendetta
uh it's where the government created a
virus and used it to seize power over
its people
and there was one incident of police
brutality that sparked a national
protest
and led a larger revolt against the
government
we're not there yet yeah that's what's
freaky yeah what happens on january 6th
i'll we'll we'll talk about this in
greater detail like i don't want to draw
the conversation but let me just say man
what happens on january 5th when the
democrats win in georgia assuming they
do
and then all these trump supporters here
the democrats now control everything
and they're in dc and they're angry they
got nothing to lose they're desperate
their property's gone their businesses
are gone their savings is gone
i'll tell you this man it's all tied
together it's just like v for vendetta
where he says i could see it all tied
together like you know web or whatever
you've got people i remember watching a
video oh wait
let me slow down i went to a bunch of
trump rallies 2015
2016 and i met a bunch of people who
were voting for trump some of them were
bernie sanders supporters
when the democrats gave it to hillary
took it from bernie some of them went to
trump they said because bernie and trump
were the only ones talking about the
trade agreements and bringing back these
jobs
i remember talking to one dude who was
probably like early 50s
and he was saying you know this was in
janesville wisconsin and he was talking
about how his job was gone gone overseas
and trump's talking about bringing these
factories back and bringing back you
know his livelihood his town and that's
what he's voting for
and then i remember seeing a video from
a couple years like a year and a half
for some of the trump's presidency
it was a dude crying he's like a
middle-aged guy crying saying before
trump
i lost my job my savings has completely
diminished
my my the college fund for my kids was
was we were eating into it
and i knew that not only was i on the
verge of not giving my kids a future
we were on the verge of homelessness
until trump came in
and started putting in these rules these
tariffs negotiating these trade
agreements
and then my companies these company
start coming back to my area
he's like now i'm working again now i'm
saving again now i know that i have my
safety net back and it's thanks to
donald trump and the guy was in tears
not bawling is out like crying but he
was like you know his tears coming out
of his face like thank you donald trump
you've saved my life i can't believe it
i imagined that video and i've talked
about that one so many times over the
past several years as one guy
having his life turn around or the
people in michigan when the car factory
started coming back and reinvesting in
the detroit area
now those people are being told it's all
being taken away from you
remember the episode of south park where
cartman gets a million dollars you see
that one
he gets a million dollars and he buys a
theme park with it
and then kyle is all like you know why
it's not fair god why would you give
cartman the worst person in the world a
million dollars
but then cartman loses the million
dollars and he's miserable and he's
crying
and he's screaming i'm not trying to
equate the hard-working people derek
hartman don't get me wrong
i'm just saying you have people who are
desperate and donald trump comes in and
in 2019 we get the best economy
of our lives so says jim cramer if you
take his word for it
these people are getting their jobs back
they're getting back on track then covet
hits the democrat governors destroy
everything shut it all down take away
your job take away your property your
chance at life
and now you're going back backwards now
we got cnbc story says
they interviewed a hundred investors
like wealth management funds
two-thirds believe under biden the
economy is gonna tank or it's gonna
start going down it's gonna get bad
now these people are watching everything
being stripped away
are they gonna show up in dc and are
they going to be really really angry
kind of think so i mean it can go either
way but
until people i don't see this issue
being resolved until people really
understand what the
hell is going on you know it's
it's not just you know i get it he
thought trump was the the nuke in the
system i'd never
assumed that never thought that he was
never supported them i mean i could say
that for any politician for that matter
but the the the idea that
the these institutions continue to grow
in power and that clue that includes
trump you know with his
executive orders that's going to set the
scene up precedent being set for joe
biden to come and basically do the same
thing
um just may not be working out to these
people's benefit
so this is why i if it keeps going that
route
the the most peaceful way is to me
a separation like this this idea that we
all have to share this one government
though we hate each other
to this point makes no sense whatsoever
this is why they're control freaks
they're control freaks it's like it's
not about
uh people being free i don't care what
dumb crap they throw out there acting as
if they give
give a crap about someone being free uh
in liberty and all these concepts no
matter what side of the political
spectrum that they claim to be on
the issue here is that these folks have
this power right this
territorial monopoly right on use of
force violence and ultimate decision
making and they say
we want that and we want to implement
that we want do you
utilize that to implement these crazy
things that you see going on
shutting folks down doing whatever it is
and it's always
claiming to be benefiting the people
that are around them this is why i say
at some point
maybe this isn't working that doesn't
mean even once we split we can't have
have a deal that says okay you got my
back i got yours but we're not sharing a
government it makes no
sense for us to share government well
weeks ago i was talking about this
and talking about a peaceful divorce and
people are like you're crazy
now i see more and more people talking
about it because when you look at the
government
it really looks like there's elements
that are trying to take away people's
ability to fend for themselves
absolutely
especially with the latest news from the
irs today that is planning a 50
increase in audits of small businesses
small businesses yes the irs is
literally hiring additional staff right
now to conduct
50 percent more audits on small
businesses literally
wiping out anyone who survived and was
left over
to get there again meanwhile amazon
walmart allowed to be open they barely
taxes themselves
how many how many audits do they do per
year on small i gotta look at the
i don't know because i think the
important question is if what if they
only do 10 audits
i'm just saying what if what if out of
out of you know we got three we got 100
we got
225 working people in this country how
many of them own small businesses
it's an important question to ask how
many audits do they do because 50
that's a percentage either way either
way i i i think it's well yeah i mean
the problem is it's like they're going
after the
i don't want to defend i know i don't
know the idea is obviously that they're
going after the little guy after the
little guys that have been
utterly destroyed this this past year
that's what they've been doing so i get
it i totally
understand why someone would you know
look at that and i was like hate the rs
and look at that and be like
you know what hey man what are y'all
doing but no
like there's something wrong with this
and the minute i can get americans
to understand that the better off we're
going to be but a lot of them are
control freaks a lot
of them just want they it's not about
liberty it's about
more so control so i want to be able to
force that person
on the other side of the aisle to do
what i want them to do and they can't
they can't
see a world where it's like okay why
don't you go do that and i'm just gonna
go
go do that that sounds crazy this is the
thing right you got states like wyoming
that's the this the true the the the
most trump state
in the country granted they only have
like 550 million people
550 000 people not millions in the state
that'd be a massive state by the way no
no 550 000 people in that state so it's
not the biggest
it's it's the most trump support of any
state and then i think west virginia
it doesn't make sense that they're going
to pass you know joe biden wants to ban
all online sales of ammo
of ammo accessories and guns i'm like
well that might make sense for new york
we talked about it
you know what do you what do you do if
someone's breaking into your little
concrete cubicle that smells like sour
milk
maybe it doesn't make sense to fire you
know 556 which might go through the wall
but people will might do it if they're
if they just have it so then there's
questions about density
but if you're in west virginia if you're
in wyoming it definitely makes sense to
have you know an ar-15
when you're dealing with animals in fact
i don't even know depending on which
which a are using what what
kind of ammo can use might not even be
able to actually stop a large bear or
some animal that's attacking your home
you might need some serious firepower
for that
so in new york they're like these
politicians say we need to ban all these
guns how stupid must you be to have like
a
458 you know socom or 450 bushmaster or
something
in new york city and then somebody who's
in the middle of the wilderness is like
are you nuts i definitely need that
stopping power
and that's why is that law gonna affect
them right but and that's the problem
like why do we have this setup where
everybody can pack
uh pack up whether it be in washington
or wherever they're they're at
and they can vote law vote in laws or
rather legislation that can
impact people in wyoming that doesn't
make sense it doesn't make any sort of
sense when you break it down like that
but we just for the longest have
accepted it like that's what it is i
think right now what we're seeing is how
much of a problem it actually is
when you get people that are ruled over
by folks that they hate
so that like we saw that definitely over
the last four years how the leftists
just went utterly insane
because a guy never mind he's actually
probably more like them than any
republican president right right they
don't even understand that
but just that's why they hate him maybe
that's maybe that's they see they see an
image of themselves right
coming into fruition but no that's the
problem and
uh i think that we have to realistically
talk about that as a legitimate solution
like
why does it have to be that we all share
this particular government and it's a
lot easier we accept the idea that it's
a
lot
easier for uh americans to fight the
like federal government as opposed to
let's say the
i don't know the united nations or
something like that and it's obviously a
lot easier for me being out of uh
texas to fight the texas government as
opposed to
the federal government why is it that we
all have to share this government it's
just like because we don't
yeah i'll put it this way right there's
there's definitely
too much federalization happening
because we could have one federal
government so long as the
states had you know more guarantees and
more protections the problem is
the battle is increasingly over the
national control
the damage nobody cares about their
local politicians
their city falls to crap and so they
talk about voting for someone for
congress and i'm like but congress is
federal voting not local
yeah you want someone to clean up your
state what are your state
representatives you want better
representation where you live and
you got to vote locally and that's why i
think that the complete removal of that
would have people
focusing like people be more narrowly
focused on
what's around them as opposed to acting
like bernie sanders is going to save
their life
but that's how it used to be it used to
be that the the president was chosen for
the most part
this is the figurehead well the the the
legislature of the states
ultimately you know would were deciding
who was going to be the elector
for the state and that the senators were
voted on by
i believe it was the legislature it was
it was appointment essentially
they started changing these rules to
make it more about popular vote popular
vote
to make america more of one federalized
nation than individual states
it doesn't work in the long run and it
doesn't work in europe either
the crazy thing is we've been a country
for a lot longer than the european
union's been around
but one of the biggest problems because
i went i've been all over europe
and i hear from a lot of people in spain
i've been in spain i've been to germany
i've been in netherlands i've been to
the uk i've been in france
they tell me at greece one of the
challenges i was i was in greece and i
was asking this dude
he was a dr he was an uber driver and he
was talking about how the economy is
really really bad it's really hard to
make any money and i was like but can't
you just move to like london
and he goes i'm greek i don't want to
move to london and i was like but it's
the eu
you know you could go and the jobs are
better they're like no i'm i'm greek man
i'm not british
they don't view themselves the same way
they don't want to live under the same
rules they want to eat the same food
they're very different people and
there's nothing wrong with that that's
not
for sure right right but that's the but
just to finish my point right the u.s
it's very very similar people in west
virginia want to go hunting with their
gigantic it's a
different place for i know you can say
this because you've traveled and you i
know you especially lou
we can all say this for those of us that
travel you can be
in even certain parts of a state and
it's like
night and day like i i lived in corpus
christi corpus christi is nothing like
dallas fort worth
for those of you for those of you that
don't know and unfortunately because of
this
hyper emphasis on like uh they talk
about this diversity thing right and it
has nothing to do with thought or
anything like that what they really want
is this
different colors and different genders
of people saying the same thing
yes right that's exactly what they want
but
what i where i've been i've has gotten
me in trouble a lot like i embrace
those differences there's nothing wrong
with the fact that people in that on
that side of the country
they just act different they're
culturally different they're what they
what they value is a little different
so again why is it that we're trying to
do this once that was the problem with
covet we saw this
it was a one-size-fits-all approach why
are we treating new york
i mean at some point it was kind of a
shift but why was new york being treated
like texas
like it's not the same like they don't
how they live even
even in new york like upstate versus new
york city they're not the same
so i'll put it this way man because
we've talked about the peaceful divorce
scenario
it's pretty popular a lot in the sense
that a lot of people are talking about
it
and we brought we brought us up a couple
times but i'm i'm i'll say this man they
like the left likes to say that the red
states will be a third world country
i i've i've talked about how cool is
that ancient technologies youtube
channel where the guy builds mud huts
and like clay pots and stuff i'm like
i'm totally down to build my own little
cabin
and you know we're talking about getting
this massive farmland
like open land in west virginia just so
we can build and do our thing use our
hands
and and have our own space start from
scratch yeah built
just like that sounds fun yeah i'm not
worried about going to new york city
i haven't lived in new york city in a
couple in several years now i got out of
there i was like i don't like you know
at a certain point
i really liked the idea of being in this
dense urban jungle
and or concrete jungle and then at a
certain point i was like i can't do
anything
no you can't you can't do anything i
couldn't even have a moped i couldn't
you couldn't even drive a car
there's there's you can't even park in
manhattan i'm like this sucks
you can't get around you know what's
really funny you know we're out in the
middle of nowhere
but we're still really close to like a
good airport and i was worried i'm like
man it's pretty far away
and then i realized if you live in new
york city if we did this show in new
york city
and we wanted to fly in a guest if if
you were in brooklyn for instance
williamsburg maybe popular hipster area
no matter what airport someone lands at
it's like an hour or two hours to get
there
it's only like five or seven miles
that's how that's how
jammed up and congested and awful these
cities are
sitting in the car in traffic with stop
lights you can't move ten bucks to go
through the tunnel or whatever i'm just
like dude i want to live in the
mountains
and it's crazy how considering that
there are actually people that want to
move towards a direct democracy
where folks in areas like that get to
rule over
or more so make rules on behalf of yes
they want to get rid of the electoral
college yeah exactly i think we really
have to understand here that collective
centralization is psychotic yeah i think
we just need to understand that let's
get it let's get it out there
it's crazy it's insane if you think that
one person could know what's best for
everyone and that's basically the idea
of the left of communism of more
and more progressive leaders that think
that they know what's best for you
and there's two groups of people the the
people who believe that and the people
who just want to be left alone
create two separate territories let
people who want to be left alone on this
side
people who don't want to be left alone
love the nanny state love being told
what to do
love getting slapped around like getting
their toys taken away like being fined
and penalized for living their life like
they do
if you like that you like dominatrix or
whatever you go
you go to that side of the country it's
okay i don't
blame you hey i'm a free-minded person
you do whatever you got to do
can't you do this in parts of mexico
like aren't there places where there's
like no cops and you can just like do
your thing like in chiron
yes tehran i visited there personally i
did a little small documentary on it on
my youtube channel
and it's a city of 30 000 people that
kicked out the police
kicked out the government and in doing
so kicked out the cartel
and it was in one of the most dangerous
states michoacan
where people were dying more than
anywhere else in all of mexico
now that city chiron is one of the
safest places in all of mexico even
though it's surrounding by all this
all the violence and there wasn't a
murder there within
seven years ever since they got rid of
this and they live under
a kind of anarchistic system but they
have community meetings and they decide
there's nothing for them it is
individual exactly and they are armed
to the teeth and the mexican government
keeps trying to disarm them
but they say no and they have their own
checkpoints literally banning
politicians and banning any political
slogans
any political banners any political
stickers if you have a political sticker
and you want to enter their town they're
going to make you take it off they
literally have checkpoints with guys
with
uh you know ar-15s saying nope you're
not coming in let me give a shout out to
those antifa leftists who are constantly
saying very very similar things that you
don't need government that you can work
live cooperatively and have community
meetings and everyone gets by
but you know i'll tell you the one thing
that probably made me
like i've always been fairly libertarian
a lot of policy issues i've like look
i'm a skateboarder
so i grew up in the city and i'm like
skateboarders have a problem with
authority man you just want to be left
alone
but i i go to west virginia and again
like i said i'm driving around at all
these houses
everywhere and i'm like there's no cops
none
none i mean there are sheriffs i guess
there are some cops
but people are saying oh man if you call
them it's like an hour before they get
here now i lived in miami
and it was very much like that and the
one thing you always hear about like
where's the crime it's like well
everybody's armed you know
our society is a flight side let's say
right west virginia has some of the most
second amendment second amendment
friendly kind of initiatives
more than i think uh you know the
majority of the united states i remember
we were driving through it and i'm like
i haven't seen a police officer once and
then you started laughing like yeah i'm
like this is amazing this is awesome
i like this place why doesn't antifa
move to west virginia man well the thing
is
they're frauds man let's be i want to be
clear they are complete frauds
those guys are and i think maybe it does
stem from them being so anti-private
property rights but these guys have
no problem with utilizing like
when we talk about the antifa type so
these kind of progressive uber
progressives
claim to be uh anti even they they throw
out the slogans of defunded police but
really all they wanted to do was replace
it with the woke police
yeah that was more so what it was that's
what makes them frauds and this is why i
don't ally myself
there's like black children that were
shot and killed exactly like well let me
here's the outcry let me tell you
something we we were
luke and i were downstairs earlier we're
talking about setting up like getting
this like 100 acres it's
cheap man 100 acres in the middle of
nowhere west virginia is not expensive
especially if people come in pool their
resources and so we're talking about the
fun things we can do what we can build
have all this free space just be left
alone
and i'm i'm i'm saying where's the left
to go and do this you want you want your
commune you can build it
but let me tell you a story and you
might remember this during occupy wall
street i've told this to the audience i
don't
you've probably not heard this someone
donated a farm to the occupiers
to the activists and so a bunch of these
people moved
upstate to live on this farm and be
self-sufficient
self-sustainable and it was a leftist
dream man no pollution no carbon
you know they were taking care of the
animals and living off the earth they
had collectives where they shared their
own food and guess how long
i'm sure some of the people like stayed
for a long time it was a huge territory
by the way
but let me say the of the people i knew
at occupy
how do you think how how long do you
think they they lasted how long do you
think they they made it
on this farm to put up that's tough so
so they moved from the city
urban liberals oh so they to a farm to
to live on off the earth
how long do you think they made it i'm
gonna say i'm gonna say i'm gonna
and i think i'm actually overshooting
i'm gonna say three months two weeks
two weeks so i i had some friends who
came with me oh
i had some friends that were like we're
gonna go live on this farm man and they
were talking about
the banks are ripping us off they're
like if we're working on the farm and
we're growing our own food we're not
getting taxed on that
they can't take that from us and so
we're not going to contribute to climate
change we're not going to contribute to
these banks to
you know extracting our value and we're
going to be relying on ourselves
and then you know it happened when they
came back i was like you were gone for
two weeks
like what happened it wasn't it fun and
they were like dude you wake up at 6 a.m
you go to bed at midnight and you're
working non-stop the whole time
no days off never and i laughed and i'm
like what did you think it meant
exactly to live on a farm dude did you
think you were gonna go there and put
your feet up and chew on [ __ ]
the answer yes yes the answer is yes yes
no they seriously like
hold on i knew one or two people there
that were good people no
hearted people a bunch of people like
totally were interested but i do
remember
them saying they had this huge territory
and they were recruiting for it hard
because
no one went a few people went one of the
two
two of the people were really great
human beings and i think that there are
some people that did stay on that farm
and did eventually start working on the
land and stood there a lot longer than
two weeks but as you said uh that
doesn't
really but that's what you're saying to
me with the with the ideology and what
it is that they
like it's like when we talk about it
being maybe a pipe dream i don't think
these guys understand work and
we talked about this in yesterday's show
about how
you know they don't understand farming
that's not anything that is even
this is why it's so easy for them for
someone like in portland or something
like that to just sit up here
and say well you guys got all the money
you guys got all the resources just give
us the resources they don't understand
like
how that how those resources get to
point from point a
to point b that's not even it's just
because they have so easy access
thanks thanks to uh the market being not
only we don't have a free market by any
means it's freer than a lot of other
places
you know that song money for nothing
yeah money for nothing and the chicks
for free
it's this i uh my understanding of the
song was that the was it the rascal
flats who wrote that
that they overheard dire straights
yeah what is that is that that's a
country band oh okay anyway
i have no idea what i'm talking about
anyway these apparently there were guys
who were watching one of their music
videos or something like this
and thought it was easy like
everything's always easy it reminds me
of
so many people who think man i should
i'm in the wrong business i should be on
youtube
it's so easy
yeah like oh yeah it's just ease them
like i do it right do it if it's that
easy then they don't
and they don't because they don't
understand it it's like they see
they see the outcome more than anything
like they don't see the fact that you
have to work beating on your craft
or uh you know the grinding like they i
was telling my followers today it's like
i don't think y'all understand like
tim wakes up in the morning and gets to
work like he even now like even with him
being a successful
person he gets up and and he grinds just
like we all do like it's not
coming to us you know what i'm saying we
were screaming about uh just moments ago
before we started the show i'm like we
got to go to this
thing and do the hotel thing january 6th
yeah and you're like no man i can't go
to work and which you know you got yeah
you got to respect
i think because he works extremely hard
i got to say that but also there's a
similar trend with this ideology and
people going hungry
whether it's the ussr china venezuela
zimbabwe
i'm sorry i like to eat yeah and
a lot of other people like to eat this
dude i made i made cookie cupcakes oh
man and this dude ate all of them i
come from poland and in poland if
there's food on the table you can eat it
but if you don't finish it
that grandma is going to hit you well
hold on hold on and why isn't it over
your head and why is that because we
went through stars because of the ussr
that literally brought in communism
welfare for the people
we're going to take care of everyone
you're going to have to buy everything
on a piece of paper that the government
mandates
literally starved so many people uh
and my family went through hell
absolutely it goes back to though what
you were saying
earlier about why it's so important why
do we advocate for free of markets in
the division of labor and all of those
things that a lot of progressives or
communists would generally say
uh is a bad thing it's this idea that
a group even a group of people that's
what 330 plus million people
in this country like this idea that a
handful of people can just dictate
how much something must cost how much
something uh you know how we can
allocate all of these resources
for that many amount of people is insane
and nowhere
in history uh at definitely at well at
least at that large of a scale
has that work you talked about the ussr
you got understand what got them
overages and and shortages it's that
central planning or this idea that
if we can get a group of people with a
vote elected or someone came down with
the iron fist
we wouldn't get a group of people to to
to force you all to give us the stuff
and we allocated y'all gonna be all
right but you're wrong
you're wrong yeah where else would sri
lanka get their speed boats if it wasn't
for the system
where else would pakistan get their
gender studies where else would there be
book clubs in pakistan and afghanistan
if it wasn't for our system
also surrounding that important news
about government spending there's also a
new article
well so pretty fascinating no no but
this this this next story ties in
exactly what you were just saying about
these leftists saying you've got the
resources just give them to me not
realizing all the work that goes into it
so the big news we have now that came
out today is that mitch mcconnell first
of all he he objected to the two
thousand dollar stimulus
bill and everybody's complaining oh
mitch mcconnell's blocking our stimulus
or whatever
mitch mcconnell introduces two thousand
dollar aid checks bill
tied to social media immunity and
election fraud
this is really interesting stuff
basically what mitch mcconnell is saying
is i'm not gonna give you your blanket
two thousand dollars
you're gonna vote for my two thousand
dollars and here's what it says as part
of mcconnell's bill
section 230 the social media immunity
law would be repealed
and a commission on election fraud would
be created the stimulus checks would be
increased two thousand dollars from the
current six hundred
quote it will not pass the house and
cannot become
law senate democratic leader chuck
schumer said in a statement referring to
the democratic majority house of
representatives
mcconnell's office was not immediately
available for comment blah blah blah
do you think they're going to vote for
this because this is interesting stuff
i've been saying for a while you know
trump wants to repeal 230
i think it's really really bad but some
conservatives made some really good
points and i'll tell you why i think
it's bad
repealing 230 means that it's
it's the end of social media as we know
it i think
if i was going to be optimistic this
show would probably be fine
because youtube is trying to be like
netflix
and they like this show you know they
they they seem to like me and
the people i associate with or whatever
because you know it's safe i suppose
well youtube doesn't even have a problem
with you being on the show right
so here's the point if i was going to
like pitch something to netflix
you know i've actually had a lot of
discussions it's likely they'd probably
pick something up
so youtube is going to be like this is a
good show we can keep this we're safe
but they're going to get rid of all the
smaller creators
your channel eric might be at risk
because they're going to be like we
don't know this guy is we don't care
and we don't want to get sued for libel
and defamation so they're going to get
rid of anyone who's not approved
so i think ultimately it's a bad bad
idea but what's interesting is a lot of
conservatives brought a really good
point
they said tim we've already been purged
it's only good for us
if they get rid of it if we're out then
so like the
so i guess the way you put it is if
right now the media companies are
favoring progressive ideals
and restricting conservatives then the
best thing for conservatives is to nuke
the whole system
because right now they're losing because
of it well i think section 230 is going
to be abused
especially under abide in administration
that has many high-level
tech executives within it and of course
they're going to be patting and patting
each other on the back and helping each
other out
and of course the little guys are going
to get screwed over and everyone else is
going to be allowed to do what they
usually do or it's just not going to be
enforced like many of the laws that are
just there
on the books but they're not really used
at all so i think that's
a probability that we have to understand
here as well i don't know if they'd
actually move to repeal it but i know
that democrats are probably going oh
no oh i can't believe they're going to
repeal this
whatever will be due because like i said
youtube will allow my show to be around
and you know what else is going to
happen take a look at netflix take a
look at all of these big production
you know companies what kind of movies
are they making they're making woke
and far left and weird whatever yeah
they're making all of this stuff
so if you get rid of the independent
creators that's what's left
yeah with their competition though like
i've
long talked about that like we are this
is why channels like mine
uh blew up over the course of the last
you know couple of years
because of that it's like a lot of folks
are tired of that they're like all right
we're being lectured all the time in the
movies that we
watch the games that we play the comic
books that we read
and and and we don't want any of that
but the issue though
is when we talk about like i don't know
these
uber like tech companies that that take
these government i would encourage you
guys to look at that i know we talk
about corporate welfare all the time but
just go look at how much these guys get
in terms of
um the not even with the taxation but
just with
like how they work with the government
directly being in government contracts
like this big tech company yeah like
yeah exactly and why it is that they
often favor uh those more regulatory
bodies
because they're the ones that benefited
we talked about we talked about that
last show
with um i talked about the bail monopoly
like that was what what happened they
work with the state and then
it sounds good it's like hey we're
protecting you net neutrality we're
protecting you and then it's like
no it actually does not benefit you they
just worded it in a way this is supposed
to benefit you this is how the game
works
mitch mcconnell is is coming at
repealing 230 and an election
an election fraud investigation from the
left
the left argument this is really
interesting give the people their two
thousand dollars and
repeal two thirty that's that's how they
do it and although they
give you money now i think that you know
part of me i look at the repeal of 230
and like imagine if we got rid of social
media
we went back to the era of like four or
five news channels
then you'd have the restoration of many
news organizations
and a balance of competition between
perspectives and a more unified world
view
and with people in this country at least
that's the idealistic utopian
vision of what might happen in reality
what will happen is the progressive
leftists who have already gone insane
from their own platforms like jack
dorsey went nuts
jack dorsey's own creation twitter made
him crazy
and i and and i mean it you can look at
the things he believes and says
and it's a product of the far left in a
in a in a
swimming in a pool of their own filth
yeah and then they prop each other up
the likes create more likes create more
shares more retweets and then it spirals
out of control and then he starts
believing
you know the refugees coming out of his
own platform that will be what's left
there won't be this perfect system of
restoring balance and bringing back
regular and honest independent voices
nope it's too it's too late
there's a split if they get i tell you
this man if they get rid of 230
and it really does result in more
censorship and more banning it would
just accelerate everything
i think though when we talk about that
and also the other pork though you know
that we
somehow stopped talking about pakistani
gender studies yes all of that stuff
that's another way in in how they pass
stuff like that you're seeing an example
of that it's like
how can we get them to focus on that
like okay even
they want a little more cash bam a
little more cash and then it's like all
right well we'll give them 2
000. but all of that garbage is still in
there yeah right it's still
there and we're not uh i don't want to
say we're not talking about it but it's
like oh hey we're getting we're getting
a raise on
on this free money that we just printed
out in there uh
but we're not talking about that's how
it gets passed it's like if i can get
you to focus on that they do that with
titles of bills all the time where it's
like
hey this is supposed to be this and then
someone that actually reads the damn
bills like wait a minute
that's not what that is rand or some uh
something like that's not what that is i
actually read this bill
it doesn't say do exactly this this and
that and then they're like well
he's a racist because he didn't vote for
for this
the the you like black people bill or
something like that and there's all
types of garbage in it yeah if they took
the entire omnibus and just broke it up
and spread it around
automotive no no no i mean it's broken
up and said we're going to give everyone
an equal share
every american every working america
you're talking about like in the price
point that it said right now
2.7 trillion or whatever divided by 225
million working americans everybody gets
like 12 grand
12 grand another thing we need to
realize we need to stop
saying that the government is giving us
something they're not they're
borrowing it from us which we're going
to have to pay back
in taxes or with inflation for us or our
children
or our children children are going to
have to pay for this guarantee still
they're stealing from future generations
and this is why we
that's why they're not giving us nothing
yeah yeah it's the
the value what you have right now and
they're selling off assets of unborn
people that's exactly what they're doing
and the fact that people are just so
okay with that to me is what's so freaky
about it you break it down to them like
dude
that money is not there this whole myth
that you think well i'm just getting my
taxpayer money back your money's gone
they don't have it they don't they don't
have it they're they're in the red
right now and still spending it they
don't have yours we got off the gold
standard
because they borrowed your money spent
it and when you asked for it bet it said
here's a piece of paper
it's good for the money exactly people
are like all right i guess
i don't think you can go back on the
gold stand at this point a lot of people
wanted to was it
didn't trump try to appoint that lady
who wanted to get him down the gold
standard i wish that would have happened
would have been
so hard man yeah you know i just kind of
want like
i don't know if i think the system might
be too far gone but it would be nice to
be back on a track where you can
understand what's happening
and we're at this point now where it's
this massive ponzi scheme
where they just deficit spend into
oblivion which results in
like the interest being higher than the
ability to even pay anything back
so that means there's rapid inflation
it's a big ponzi scheme
and they and the reason it won't
collapse because they have guns if
donald trump was real he would have
appointed ron paul to the head of the
federal reserve
i talked to rod i'm like ron would you
do he's like yeah i'll do this in the
heartbeat
yeah that would be i think that's that's
if they wanted to if they were they
would
they would have they if they really
wanted to take an axe to the system that
would have been the guy
that they went with in 2012 to 2008 as
well
uh but no like he told me he would do it
yeah of course i know it will but
seriously guys it's like
trying to get people to it's like
pulling literally pulling teeth
out of people uh people's mouths man
trying to get them to understand
that money's not there it's like they
don't they don't get it i'm getting
these fights with
uh can i say boomer conservative is that
is that like
offensive or something like that okay
all right so you can say i'm kidding all
right yeah probably
yes i'm kidding yeah but um no and i
talk about social security
and they like seriously think well if
we're gonna take away social security
then i want my money back and i'm like
bro your money's not there
the money that you that you were you
were being taxed you've been stolen from
which is the decent portion of your
check
is gone they don't even pretend that it
is yours what's happening right now is
you're living off
of the current generation that's going
to end up in the same position why it's
a
it's a literal ponzi scheme uh in that
regards but people don't understand that
and i guess it's because maybe the state
has baby them and giving them whatever
they want check us out so so
uh you know luke and i were talking
about getting this big farm property and
what we could do if we had like our own
cryptocurrency
and it's like we want people to come and
and contribute and help us build stuff
and i'm like how do you actually create
value in a currency how do you actually
convince people it's worth something
if you can just print it out of thin air
why would anyone be like oh i want some
of that
why you're just gonna keep printing and
no one's gonna want anything from me
yeah for the background we were talking
about creating two kind of civilizations
no that's one
with a lot of government one with no
government and we're gonna think of ways
how to make
currencies we were talking about
cryptocurrencies and using some kind of
way to create
value one idea i had was to make one
working hour
a value token that people could use and
trade within the community
that's what some local communities in
ridges
but the problem is so first the context
is like
doing some kind of show where we're like
who would succeed regulation versus no
regulation
and the problem with that idea of the
hour is if someone can just
print the money arbitrarily then why
would i
do work for your currency if you're not
working and just printing it out and
getting whatever you want
from me that's what's happening right
now i know you just described american
fiscal yeah
right that's why i complain to people
when they're like just print more
when rand paul comes out and he's like
why not twenty thousand why not ubi and
i'm like
yes people don't get it no you can't
just do that
that's true but it's happening but
that's why and it's funny you guys are
having that conversation though that's
exactly why it's important
that the market be free enough for folks
that are even smarter than everybody
that's at the table right now to be able
to figure that out
and answer that sort of question this is
why people acting freely
is so important because we don't got out
of answers it's actually these
very very arrogant uh it's not just
progressives but you know it's
it's especially progressives that are
very arrogant enough to think that they
have the
all the answers and because they can't
it's one of the biggest criticisms of
what maybe luke and i more so believe in
is that well they figure well
i can't i can't possibly like conceive
an idea
or see that world actually coming to
fruition and i'm like
how arrogant of you to think you're the
smartest person to ever live that just
because you can't see that being done
it just can't be done at all you know
and it's kind of funny sorry ian go oh
yeah what we could do in a community is
we each print our own crypto
and then so if you wanted me to do
something for you
it would be five tokens you would give
me five tokens or i would give you five
tokens for your product
but if i gave you if i paid you an error
coin i only had to give you four tokens
so the value then would it would create
a value
system for all these different
currencies that we'd start inter trading
like i would give you
five tokens for four if you're going to
give me eric tokens so that we
we still make a we still come out even
except you get an extra token out of it
so and then you're gonna you're gonna
still get tokens for your
labor and get paid um and then they
could pay you five tokens of else
uh i think that would that would be how
you would do see like this conv and i
fact that what i love we have in this
conversation because these are the
conversation that
innovators have right and these are
these are these are
and this is why it's so important for
the market to be free enough so we can
have that conversation the state says
well i have the smartest people on my
team
therefore what i say has to go never
mind if it hasn't worked never mind it's
it's the possibly
the most dumbest idea it doesn't matter
i have the monopoly on law
well this is the important thing when
we're moving towards an ideology
we're moving away towards a merit-based
society and whenever we see governments
whether germany and world war
ii or the ussr before world war one
whenever they
push ideology more than they do merit
there's always a lot of destruction
because there's always a controlling of
individuals not
based on their intelligence not based on
their skills but based on their
obedience to the state
and it's interesting that they call
themselves you know individuals call
themselves progressives
when in human history you look at
innovation progression it's made
when there's very little government
absolutely and then these individuals
who want more government are calling
themselves progressives
like that that to me is just
mind-boggling it's it just shows you
that we're kind of living in a 1984
double speak world where words have
double meanings now the left
uh i i think it was jenk uger who said
this the the progressives always win
that the left always wins
and my people corrected him saying no
liberty always wins a lot of these
issues people talk about going back to
like the fight for freedom of speech in
the vietnam era was about
liberty individual rights civil rights
gay marriage all the stuff has always
has always been about individual
liberties and the rights of the
individual to do things
it's not been about your authority as
governor of new york to shut down the
economy
destroy people's lives and put up
checkpoints around your city to make
sure nobody comes in
and that almost sounds like you're just
separating yourself from the rest of
this country we've talked about divorce
before
a lot of these places already doing it
but here's here's i want to move on to
this this the subject
of what happens when people finally have
had enough because we
we did mention this a little bit earlier
in the show what happens when people
have nothing left to lose
what happens when we start seeing more
and more videos of people who are
desperate
we see these these stories about the
woman beating the cop with the with the
baton because you don't want to
wear a mask people are angry and they
don't care if you know
you guys you guys ever hear that story
about the dude who walks into a bank
and he has a note the note is a is a
robbery he's demanding one dollar
he threatens him and says give me a
dollar or else then he goes and sits
down
and he waits for the cops to come and
arrest him you know why because he had
cancer and he was going to die
and he said it's the only way i can get
treatment that's that's why he did it
the left likes to bring it up saying
that's how messed up our health care
system is
i'm like i don't think that's a good
example of how much of our health care
system is but i do think it's
interesting that our prisoners get
better health care than say like this
old guy so there's an interesting point
but this dude was desperate so desperate
he did a staged kind of robbery to go to
prison
what happens when people have nothing
left to lose they don't care about
prison
yeah no that's when the violence happens
right when people are down and out and
i think a lot of people have taken uh
for for granted that
stability i know a lot of folks even
especially progressives talk about
change and hope and stuff like that
believe it or not a lot of people don't
want that
right a lot of people are comfortable
being able to see
exactly where they're at and where
they're going to be able to go
it's when you get that sort of
unfamiliarity
where people are like i don't know when
the next check's going to come
i don't know when if i'm going to be
able to pay
they're going to take and then that's
when they start to erupt well here
here's the news
ex pence aide turned trump critic very
concerned about january 6th
violence so this hotel hotel harrington
announces they're shutting down for
three days when this dc event is
supposed to happen
and apparently it's because the
washington post claimed the proud boys
were using it as
a headquarters the proud boys apparently
came out and said that's not true we
haven't used that place for months
and they're saying now on january 6
proud boys are going to be showing up in
plain clothes
not wearing their iconic shirts and some
of them
are going to be dressed like antifa so
there's a very serious concern
that there's actual planning going into
what's going to happen
i think one of the biggest mistakes you
know i was thinking about this one of
the biggest mistakes proud boys could
make is going and fighting with antifa
right now i think that matters i don't
think trump supporters fights are with
antifa
it's with the establishment government
and the democrats antifa's biggest
mistake would be going and fighting with
trump supporters
you know it's a really interesting thing
when i see there was a a funny post by
shuon head you know shu
yeah she posted uh people i think it was
in uh a camera board state it was
do you know where this was where they're
setting up the guillotine in front of
the politicians house or whatever i
think that was in mexico
yeah mexico i think and she said cons
this could be us marching to congress
together or whatever
and i said when when trump's out of the
white house the enemy of my enemy is my
friend is gonna start looking real good
to a lot of people
yeah i mean i get that my thing is
though why i know
a lot of folks rag on me because i say i
will not allow with these types because
i know
my next is my my back against the wall
yeah you know what i mean and they're
going to put me up against it because
ultimately it's about
that's why i don't want to have them
using me as my useful idiots but
we got to talk about that though because
it's a legitimate concern but i also
think it's a lot of
leftists over this course of this last
year
have been trying to for the sake of
legitimizing their own bad behavior
trying to say that the other side would
do what it is that they would do now
keep in mind what all they've been doing
for the past i don't know months
right definitely this year of course
maybe we can talk about what's happened
before that but let's just focus on what
happened post george floyd
where you're talking about hundreds of
spots
and and in some cases where you go in
like the portlands and the seattles of
the world you're talking about months at
a time
right that they were just riding acting
up
so the reason why they do that is so
they can say hey
look at them and what they do right look
look at them when
basically to try to absolve them of the
bad
behavior i think it's likely more likely
let's say don't say likely but i think
it's more likely
that they would have that you probably
see a first big pow-wow
with guys that are quote-unquote on the
right but more so with the police
because they're they're more when they
protest this is why you don't see when
you generally they go do their thing you
don't really go see
uh wendy's get burnt down or something
like that generally when the when the
quote unquote right links up that
generally does doesn't really have
they're more precise
with what it is they do so i get the
desperation but that desperation
may have them more so turning on the and
maybe i'm just being a
an audio log right now but that
desperation may have them actually
looking to
the people who the the police more than
right right i don't i don't think trump
supporters
they're planning on going to dc setting
up tents occupying and
and protesting shutting things down i
think it's going to get pretty big i
mean you got this guy going on msnbc
saying
you know it's going to get violent and
i'm really worried about this hotel
shutting down man that's that's a crazy
signal
but what do you think is going to happen
you think antifa are going to be the
ones blocking the trump supporters from
having their protests
it's going to be the police yeah exactly
i think trump is going to be like okay
officer we're not going to protest
more president not anymore they've done
that for a while and and they know that
that's not work but listen listen when
trump was tweeting antifa bad
and the cops were fighting antifa they
had the trump supporters the proud boys
everybody at their back
saying do it we got your back now the
people blocking the trump supporters are
the cops and the cops saying get out of
my way i'm here for trump not for you
yeah so i'm curious could it you know i
i wonder how likely the possibility is
that you get the cops fighting two
different groups on two different fronts
that's interesting it'll be really
different but but i i i wouldn't be
surprised could have already seen
right-wing groups fighting with cops not
nearly as bad as how the left does it
but it but that was unheard of though
that's why it's important
to notate that because that's like not a
thing even back when the the tea party
thing was going down like it wasn't you
may had a skirmish here and there but
for the most part that was not what
happened could you imagine
if there's like a guy with a trump flag
and he's yelling at a cop and there's an
auntie of a guy 10 feet away and be a
nice folk
whoever gets that photo is is going to
be a millionaire but they're both
failing at cops
and the antifa guy looks over and says
trump's reporter yelling at the cop and
then he's like i'm not i'm not going to
get involved in that and he keeps
like i'm going to ignore that he's not
going to normally the entire guys want
to go fight the proud boys the proud
boys want to go fight antifa
but what happens when they're both
protesting the government
it's going to be interesting because i
think one of the problems is tribalism
and both sides are trying to use any
ally to get control of the white house
the problem is
for the left you see donald trump the
the establishment republicans
don't like him but they'll wait they'll
stand there and say okay fine well
trump's in charge we'll bide our time
trump supporters just want trump
so that creates a good a good bit of
unity between republicans willing to
just say okay to trump and trump
supporters who are fighting for trump
on the left the antifa people are like
yeah yeah we'll fight with you to get
rid of trump but we're not supporting
biden
yeah there's no unity on the left over
who their candidate is so they're in a
weakened position
yeah so if the if the fight is against
joe biden
and trump's gone then antiva's not going
to be fighting with the right they're
going to be fighting the cops
yeah and then the trump supporters
aren't going to be fighting with
antivirus because they're both fighting
the establishment and that's the
interesting thing like
i i don't know if that's going to be a
thing that's going to happen
because i i felt like i saw too many
times where they kind of
throughout during the obama presidency i
don't know if they've
gotten amped up enough to maybe go back
on that but during the obama presidency
there were a lot of instances in which
they could have went that route
and they decided not to in fact when it
came to the riding that was one of the
things that obama
um certainly was he had no issue coming
out and being like okay y'all y'all need
to stop when the ferguson thing and all
that stuff
went down he was he had no issue being
like okay y'all are being y'all are
being stupid
people need to remember occupy wall
street started yeah exactly obama
exactly major riots across the united
states started under obama
today i sent out a meme with a young
girl with a biden hat saying thank you
for saving us and then
biden is there looking at her in disgust
saying i'm literally going to do
everything trump did
that's all you should yeah and and we
have to understand biden is the epitome
of the establishment when you look at
his cabinet when you look at his
administration he has
goldman sachs he has large tech
executives he has
executives from all the worst possible
elements of the corporatist
world possible people are going to get a
very rude awakening to who he really is
the policies he sets forward and when he
gets into office he's not going to serve
you
he's going to serve the special
interests that put him in there
and when he does that especially with
all the civil unrest we've been seeing
it's been brewing it's been building up
i think it would be naive to think that
there's going to be peace
civilly in the united states coming
forward from here oh yeah this is why
this is why the democrats rely on low
information voters
it's why they want the voting age to be
16 because these people who are in their
20s who voted for biden
aren't old enough to remember joe biden
killing kids
in foreign countries and obama's extra
judicial assassinations
dumb people are also let's be honest
here more violent
so when you have a whole bunch of dumb
violence people get angry
you're you're you're you're brewing a
recipe for disaster yeah no they were
there useful idiots i mean we saw that
with black lives matter not getting a
seat at the table like their little
civil rights uh it's more of the civil
like the establishment civil rights
guys that were linking up with with bad
and black lives matter didn't get a seat
at the table and they were all
frustrated like
we demand a seat and i was like like
dude they've been using y'all for useful
idiots for the last i don't know
how how long it's not like they care
that y'all not understand much of what
y'all y'all didn't get much you gotta
get anything out of bad and pres
excuse me out of an obama presidency
what makes you think that you will be
prioritized
uh they may campaign on that but what
makes you think they're gonna prioritize
you
uh once they get in but but i'll tell
you we talk about dumb violent people
right
there's actually a better uh way to
predict if someone's going to be violent
do they have anything to lose well a lot
of these young people don't they got no
jobs they got no family
a worthless degree worthless degree now
they're seeing all this violence
look at the george floyd riots people
are locked up in their concrete cubicles
that smell like sour milk
in new york city perfect storm and so we
we had we had the comedian ryan long
let me let me think with comedian ryan
long on the show and he was talking
about when the protests and rides
started happening it was like well i can
go outside now right
a lot of these people in new york don't
have kids so they go to jail so what
they lose their job well it doesn't
matter right they're angry they have
nothing to lose
well now we have trump supporters and
regular people whose businesses no
longer exist
they can't feed their kids even if they
want to they got nothing
left to lose and so that's when people
snap another kind of
vague scientific term brought up here is
that also people who don't get laid
also are more violent very true and we
have seen also a huge increase of the
use of
only fans and also other online stores
people who don't get violent yes yes
that's one of the big predictions
it's it's your intelligence it's if
you're if you're you're
not only your intellect but also your
social intelligence
uh your social iq that also matters and
uh
if you're not getting some you're going
to have to have to release that pent-up
energy
somewhere else if you look at something
like the portland uh mug shots you can
kind of
you kind of yeah you don't feel like
there's anything
there's that meme about male feminists
like they're predators yeah there's that
there's a meme race at the clock
and it's because a lot of these guys
think in order to get with a woman they
gotta pretend to be a feminist yeah
yeah exactly and oh i'm so feminist too
look at me and
then the women don't respect them and
then they they they get angry when the
women walk up
won't hook up with them and then we get
all these stories story for story these
male feminists turn out to be rapists or
abusers
yeah creepers the biggest creeps are the
ones pretending to be something that
they're not
and they're always saying but they're
like but i said everything she wants me
to hear
she said do you know that and like what
do you think people don't respect
you patronizing them and this is the
whole thing when it comes to
the whole black lives matter there's so
many examples of this there's so many
initiatives by the establishment
by the elites for you not to be a true
genuine
person for you to be corporate replicas
of what they want you to be
that it's leading to dysfunction and
this dysfunction is a byproduct of this
curated algorithm of this mainstream
media of this entertainment industry
that is shaping people's minds
to be destructive because when you're
destructive
you of course are going to have to be
obedient to the big overlord that is
going to beat you over the head and tell
you exactly what you're doing
here's what you need to do you need to
eat right you need to exercise
you need to meditate you need to take
care of yourself you need to protect
yourself
and think you need to get something but
but no listen listen
yes but if you start with improving
yourself let's like there's a lot of
people
you know we were talking about you know
how good it feels to like to be to take
care of yourself
people don't realize and i was reading
this post on reddit about being fit
being and having you know exercising
that a lot of people don't like
exercising right
what they don't realize these people who
don't exercise is that if you
exercise consistently you feel good all
the time
you wake up feeling like a million bucks
you're like oh you could like you feel
like you could punch a bear in the face
and the bear would run away you know
you're like
you feel great but these people don't
take care of themselves the first thing
you got to do
take care of yourself do some exercise
eat better food
portion control stop think read meditate
study yourself analyze yourself be
honest with yourself and then you'll get
something those are right because then
you're gonna be a nice well right
this is well this is something we were
talking about maybe highlighting the
vlog on having a vlog about bettering
yourself we were talking about maybe
doing
ice bats and saunas and we're getting a
little sensory deprivation
yeah yeah so we're talking about doing
all that stuff a part of a vlog and to
just be examples of
trying to be the best version of
ourselves but that's what progressives
like definitely the mainstream ones
that's not what they want
you know what i mean and this is why
they actually shun those who try to put
some sort of responsibility
and accountability in the individual
right um
and it's obviously in all the policies
that they advocate that hey you don't
better you don't better yourself be
be destructive be dysfunctional uh and
we will give you this and you know the
minute you start trying to show some
uh you know shed some light you we're
going to strip everything
away from you so like i said in
yesterday's show they incentivize you
to fail progressive policies and why
they advocate what it is that they
advocate you need to look at the fact
that
what are they scared of why are they so
scared of people being free why are they
so
scared of liberty and and who who who
protects these ideas the academia
and educational elites and why is it
that they don't place the emphasis
on okay instead of the state or this
group of people moving your world can't
you move your world for you
did you just fat shame me eric i did
okay
i'm not one of those body positive guys
but think about the body body positivity
stuff they're basically saying
you don't need to change the world needs
to change for you
think about how narcissistic that it is
no it's not progressive either
and insane it's destroying the whole
health
the medical industry with overloading it
with individuals who think it's good to
be
unhealthy yeah and then they want free
health care how do you combine universal
health care with people encouraging you
to be
out of shape unbelievable it's healthy
at every side i think it's absolutely
hilarious to have
the people who talk about fat phobia
also telling you to wear a mask yeah
there's a contradiction there that
people need to realize what's happening
you're wrong you're wrong go ahead the
people who are dying of covet are the
overweight people
yeah they want you to wear a mask
because they're the ones who are going
to die so
so what it is what it is and go to that
point what it is is again
they don't want to be responsible for
themselves they want you to be
responsible for them
listen eric you got to wear a mask
because if you choose to go outside you
might you might get me sick when i go
when you go outside right that's exactly
what
happened but no like accountability is
for me that's been liberating that's one
of the most liberating things that
that when i had my political awakening
you know and and
one of the most the things that i
realized
being accountable for my actions and
being responsible which is
that's the trade-off with freedom right
it's that you don't have that government
guarantee you don't have that
that that it's not it's not even a
safety net it's what it is is
encouraging you
to not be great right and one of those
things where that i realized was that
okay i
can there are things that are within my
power i would always go out of my way
to find even in failure right if i did
if i wanted to achieve
something i didn't i always looked to
what could i have done
to better my situation i say this was
athlete i got my tail i
remember getting my like getting the
does blow it off of me my first freshman
year track meet eastern kentucky was
where it was at
i thought i was the you know a state
qualifier coming from texas five
five a i'm like oh yeah i'm i'm i'm it
first
indoor i never ran into a track first
indoor track meet i got the doors blowed
off of me
right and and it was it was and instead
of you know
looking at okay well it's it's indoor i
suck indoors
i can't run indoors i had to look at it
from a standpoint if i wanted to get
better
um and over the course of my track and
my collegiate track career
was okay what was it that i did was it
was i in my dry phase too long was i did
i come out of my dry phase two or this
little stuff like that
to try to improve my life but that's not
what people want what people
want is for someone else to promise them
that we will make your life better you
you just just be you know be a loser for
all they care you are not going to be
held accountable for your actions you
are not going to be held responsible and
that can be said for a multitude of
different things this is one of the
hard things that people don't want to
discuss when we talk about poverty they
always
talk about folks in poverty as if they
are the only ones like they got there by
way of some i don't know white man
sitting around the corner pulling the
strings
and it made them be poor i've seen
people ruin their own lives
that are in that pop-up that poverty
population this is what i think is funny
you know like i always thought about
people who play say like world of
warcraft
and they they make a character a hunter
and they go on quests
and i'm like why don't you just you know
like go hunt like be a real hunter
and i i look at these video games where
people play a character and they get
that dopamine reward
they're not improving themselves but i
understand there's a real career in
playing games
absolutely not not disparaging that but
i think like
wouldn't you know for me i don't like
watching people do things i like doing
things
yeah i got some people like watching but
for me it's like wouldn't you rather go
out to that field and actually go hunt
the boars
well no i mean when you talk about
gaming at least with me um i think that
that kind of the the accessibility i
talk about this all the time about
that's ruining gaming too it's not it's
like all these mediums are being ruined
by this concept that
we see this in like the fighting game
community uh where
you know people that aren't fighting the
games that got too hard taking away the
combos because they want everybody
have you played marvel vs capcom
infinite yes i threw that game in the
trash
i grew up playing marvel versus capcom
frozen for me is a fighting arcade game
and when you're playing right there's
some you know eric you've played
marvelous.com too
you do air combos yes you jump up you
land in front of the bad guy
you're your opponent you press down and
fierce punch to knock him in the air and
then you got to do a combination of
light medium punches to do your air
combo
and then i get marvel vs capcom infinite
the new version i'm all excited it's a
few years ago
and i put it in and the only thing you
got to do is press circle over and over
again
one button and i was like i'm not even
playing and and he jumps for you it's
all automatic i'm like it's not a game
anymore dude exactly
oh what what is it i i just really know
that we're doing it we're doing a
running competition tomorrow
we're putting it on my instagram up the
hill here and and one thing i wanted to
add to what you were saying is they
don't want you great they don't want you
free they don't want you independent
because when you are you can't be
subjugated
and that's the name of the game a lot of
people have been brainwashed
have been tricked have been conditioned
have been programmed
to accept their obedience to individuals
that take advantage of them and screw
them over
and who is they the aliens yes
moving on to the next story finally we
get to talk about the failures
i'm kidding the day is not really the
aliens but uh you guys can't see this
video
but i don't know if you guys saw this in
west virginia there was a weird ufo
spotted in the sky that looked like
people are saying it's a ufo crashing to
earth because there's like
flames coming out of it check out this
video so this video was uploaded on the
27th
ufo crashing to earth caught on camera
in west virginia
now a lot of people have said it's
easily explained what you're looking at
is the contrails of a jet reflected
in the sunlight the issue is the trails
end
in if you look up these uh sunset
contrails
i don't know this this channel is ghost
that hunt bag or something if you look
up
contrails from a jet in the sunlight
you'll see there's like it looks like
fire
but the the the the what is it the water
vapor that comes out of the planes
stays there in this video it's really
weird it looks like
it looks like there's two distinct
streaks of fire coming out of some weird
object in the middle
nobody knows what what it is so far now
people are saying it's an airplane i
don't know for sure but i got good news
for everybody
because we have this omnibus bill right
yeah now now all
of a sudden people are like look i'm
here for aliens man i don't know what
you're talking about omnibus bill okay
hold on hold on 5 500 page bill
get sent to congress and somebody snuck
in
i'm assuming they snuck it in a
provision in this ridiculous bill nobody
read
something a provision mandating that the
pentagon
reveal their information on ufos
at least they got that and they could
have put there's so many things that
could have gone into this
they you know i don't i don't know how
these these government bills work where
no one reads it but someone knows what
they put in there
how does that work could you just be
like what if the aliens are writing a
bill
what what if what like how does this
bill work right do i get just like write
a provision saying i get a million
dollars and just slide it in nobody
reads it and they vote for it basically
so why doesn't anybody do that whoever
slid that in thank you
so much i appreciate you very much and
we need more of you now will
a lying government tell us the truth
about aliens
well that's a whole nother well let's
see what they say over at new york post
they say president trump's signature
sunday and the 2.3 trillion covet 19
relief and government funding bill
started a 180-day countdown for the
pentagon and spy
agencies to say what they know about
ufos
the provision received very little
attention in part because it wasn't
included in the text of the 5593 page
legislation but as a committee comment
attached to the annual intelligence
authorization act
which was rolled into the massive bill
the senate intelligence committee
chaired by marco rubio said in a comment
it directs the director of national
intelligence in consultation with the
secretary
secretary
of defense and the heads of such other
agencies to submit a report within 180
days
of the date of the enactment of the act
to congressional intelligence and armed
service committees
on unidentified aerial phenomena the
report
must address observed airborne objects
that have not been identified
and should include a detailed analysis
of unidentified phenomena data collected
by
a geospa by a geospatial intelligence
b signals intelligence c human
intelligence and d
measurement and signals intelligence the
report must also contain
detailed analysis of data of the fbi
which was derived from investigations of
intrusions of unidentified aerial
phenomena data over-restricted united
states airspace
and an assessment of whether this
unidentified aerial phenomena activity
may be attributed to one or more
foreign adversaries what if they didn't
include
aliens then does the pentagon just not
get to tell us if it is
because they put four in adversaries
they say former pentagon and legislative
officials confirmed tuesday
to the publication the the debrief the
packet that the package begins the clock
on ufo disclosures so there's a lot more
uh here's a quote from we got this guy
chris mellon former deputy assistant
director of defense intelligence
told the debrief the newly enacted
intelligence authorization act
incorporates the senate intelligence
committee's report
committee's report language calling for
an unclassified all source report
on uap phenomenon this was accomplished
in the joint uh
explanatory statement accompanying the
bill assuming the executive branch
honors this important request
the nation will at long last have an
objective basis
for assessing the validity of the issue
and its national security implications
this is an extraordinary and long
overdue opportunity so i want to go back
to that image
of that weird ufo that looks like it's
on fire and crashing down earth what is
it
we'll never we won't know but maybe
we'll find out soon huh
i don't know man like y'all do y'all
believe it's like
aliens in general i don't know i don't
think it's aliens no you don't think it
is
i believe in aliens i don't know if that
is aliens but do you think that
whatever after talking to some
high-level government officials do you
think that personally told me
that aliens do exist yes i personally do
believe that they're here though
i think so yes not in this room
specifically
i mean again we can't definitively prove
this without a shadow of a doubt
there is some circumstantial evidence
that i think is somewhat convincing but
this year we have to also understand
there have been a lot of government
admissions when it comes to aliens
this is not the first time that this
subject was brought up
we have learned this year that the
government lied about a secret pentagon
unit
that they said never existed that's
tracking a lot of this stuff so they
actually
are doing something they do have some
data will they
share it with the american public that's
that's another thing but i think it's
probable
to believe that something else is out
there do i have definitive proof no i do
not
but isn't witness testimony
circumstantial evidence
yeah it's a certain circumstance what's
that dude in canada
um he's the former defense minister of
of canada
i got to look up his name to tell you
and he said yup they're aliens
well and then you got the israeli space
security agency guys saying the same
thing this year yeah
former head of the israeli space program
came out and said
very similar things to what the former
minister of defense for
canada said is that there's a alien
federation
that there's aliens trying to keep the
peace the galactic federation
so so i was thinking something i was i
was playing my ps5 the other day right
and there's this game i saw a trailer
for i think it's called stray
and i guess i don't the game is about i
guess you play cat but uh
yeah you see it and on the wall it says
rip humans
and then the people are actually all
robots and i thought about like what
would happen if humans created a bunch
of robots to do
tasks then humans died off what those
robots do just keep going i'm like what
if
aliens created humans but then left and
now humans are like
that's why we're like what are we what's
our purpose we don't know we have all
these crazy philosophical questions
and the reality is we just don't have
one you know the aliens came made humans
left because they didn't need to
use human labor anymore and now they're
chilling watching be like what are they
doing they're like building cities why
it's not doing anything i have the same
question with this one that we
that i had with the one that happened in
china you know it apparently crashed
down to the earth
why don't we go to the site and see if
we can find any pieces of it did the
whole thing burn up is there absolutely
no evidence left
like why can't we find some kind of
something to tell us what it might have
been
because if it was just a jet it's up in
the air yeah i think we should begin it
start telling us what was there right
start start giving us the
evidence and proof of what was actually
there and then let the people decide
themselves you don't have to tell us
who what where and and what specifically
you think happened
just show us exactly what happened and i
think that level of transparency that
level of accountability
is dearly needed within our government
and
uh i mean this is something i personally
want i was there at the storm area 51
protest
eagerly waiting livestream and
it was like it was like a cheap man's
burning man
but uh i'm still shocked how we went
from storm area 51 in one year to social
distance
stay home to stop the to stop the curve
or whatever
in just a matter of a year let me tell
you guys a crazy story do you guys ever
hear about the
o'hare airport ufo yes from you so
i i worked for american eagle airlines
it's a regional airline for american
airlines
from 2004 2006 and then shortly after i
quit
a bunch of people working at the airport
saw a ufo come down from the clouds and
hover in place for a few minutes
and then shoot straight back up to the
clouds punching a hole in it
everybody at the airport saw everybody
working saw it so i knew a bunch of
people still worked there i had friends
who worked there and they were like dude
we saw it it was crazy i knew one dude
who said so there's a road
outside of o'hare airport called
mannheim road
and my my friend said people in their
cars were stopped like way at the light
and then when it came down from the sky
people got out of their cars and were
just staring at it
like just just like watching it this was
before the era of you know like the
iphone and a lot of smartphones
some people had phone cameras and so
there was a pilot
who looked out his window and he took a
picture of it and the photo actually
exists on google you can pull it up
it's difficult to find because a bunch
of people made fake photos
yeah and it's it's a real bummer but the
real photo you can still find it
and you can you can faintly see it the
crazy thing is
where are all these people that got out
of their cars on manheim road and just
stood there staring at this ufo
and then they said it was it was a
weather phenomenon and i knew people who
worked at the airport they were like
dude no way
like it came down and hovered and you
could see it and then it shot sort of
punched a hole in the cloud what was
that
magnetic craft magnetic aluminum maybe
lightweight yeah i would imagine
something
you're actually describing with the ufos
yeah like a fusion power source and
being moved around by a magnet or
something
so does aliens no it's human oh
it's tesla could be yeah i mean there's
many people with many different beliefs
there's religious people who are talking
about demons
and other kind of energetic entities out
there there's of course conspiracy
theorists who are saying ufos aliens
there's other conspiracy theories saying
that this is advanced government
technology that they're keeping away
from the people
there's many different belief systems
out there but i think again
we should start with the government
telling us the truth and stop
classifying and hiding information from
the general public the problem i think
that's a great
flapper lied under oath blatantly and
they they lie about everything yeah
so i have zero so what would you yeah
like even if they did come out and say
and i think that's
they know that right they don't have to
say anything just show us what happened
yeah well that's the thing
who knows what that's going to be though
you know the way they approach it is
that they're not i don't think they're
completely oblivious to the fact that
okay if we say that something
uh is going to happen they don't trust
us enough to tell the truth
right so like is is it even if they came
out with something said this is what it
was it was an alien the
the fear is that if aliens revealed
themselves to us the world would tear
itself apart
and i hear a lot of people who but hold
on people in america might be able to
accept it
people in the us might be like wow i
guess aliens we can accept like
it's like lizard people but what are we
are carrying each other apart
no no no no no no what about other
cultures and other countries that are
way more fundamentalist and would go
insane and press the nuke button
and just go nuts america i don't
i don't think that would happen you
don't you think everyone in the world
would be like oh aliens are real and
they're holding hands and singing under
the rainbow no
no i'll tell you what happened the
aliens would come here and then everyone
would be in competition to get access to
that technology
of course imagine if they already are
this is why china built one of the
largest kind of satellites in the world
trying to read uh signals from outer
space it's a weird argument because it's
like if dogs could talk
people would go crazy so maybe dogs can
talk what do you mean well i mean
are you purporting that there's aliens
because if they if there were they
wouldn't have
revealed themselves because if aliens
reveal themselves the world will tear
that's not that's one of the fears
argument for their being aliens because
if dogs
are taught what do you what does that
could fly but they never flew
ian what are you talking about i could
levitate but i never have to do with
anything
are you making the argument that there
might be aliens because if
if they revealed themselves they would
drive people crazy so i'm not revealing
this i'm saying
what i'm saying there is a fear that if
aliens if the government did tell us the
truth and revealed to the world aliens
existed
it could cause internet but if the
government told us that dogs could talk
it might also
make international except they can't
what do you mean well
and there's no aliens what is what does
dogs talking have to do with light speed
travel and
and and ion cannons and creating like
you're suggesting like a dog's talking
your impossibility might be real
no it isn't aliens aliens visiting earth
is like a 0.000000
actually you're totally wrong what is
the actual likelihood that intelligent
life intelligent life exists in the
universe is
i believe i believe that and so there's
questions as to why we're not
encountering them because it's one
is called i think it's called the great
zoo hypothesis that they treat the earth
like a forest preserve and ignore it
there's a bunch of theories about this
but the mathematical probability that
aliens exist and that they're
substantially more advanced than us
is mathematically very high and so the
question in fermi's paradise is why
haven't we
seen them yet and there's a bunch of
different hypothetical answers as to why
that would be
so we don't know so what i'm saying is i
don't i'm not saying aliens are here
i have no idea we have no evidence to
say that except for this the fantastic
reports of flying crazy vehicles at
o'hare and
and and you know or whatever but that
could just be military tech and it's
substantially more likely it is
but as i was pointing out one of the
concerns as we're talking about the
government keeping secrets is a fear
that if the world found out right now
about aliens that's what they say though
that's why it's classified right because
people would lose their minds do you
think they would lose their mind eric
that's i think i think it goes back to
culture
because that's a great point i think we
you know yes we have this sort of
diverse culture in america but if
when you talk to other cultures about um
you know nobody pockets of africa and
and like that see the world just
fundamentally different than what it is
that we do
i think that they would react in a
different way i think
a lot of americans come to term i think
it'd be a lot more curiosity
curiosity than anything because at that
point it's like if we get a confirmation
of something that we we assume that
we've seen all it's been
embedded in our culture aliens right we
got movies movies and
x-files yeah yeah yeah show tv shows
like it's this assumption that
well we have this assumption and how
they look hell they might look like us
who knows
how exactly they will look but we have
all of these theories but
i think a lot of americans assume that
that's a thing now what they rip each
other apart is an interesting question
but i think that it would be more than
anything if there was an emotion
it would be more so a curiosity because
it's like if you confirmed right now
let's say if the
government said i win got like trump on
his way out scorched earth
i'm not gonna be the president bit bam
here's the proof right
here there's a video here's a video
here's his and he's a matter of fact it
is
and it's trump giving thumbs up yeah
yeah like and it's like oh
4k hd and everything they're eating
mcdonald's yeah
it's as advanced as you can possibly get
i think at that point i know at least
speaking on on i'd be like just
curious like more than anything else
yeah i wouldn't want to fight my
neighbor yeah
what do you think would happen if a
video came out of trump hanging out with
aliens china would go nuts
china would declare war or something
that's a good teacher and that's i think
that's where it goes back to the culture
because it's like at that point it's
like oh wow
they have access to this advanced sort
of they're getting hooked up
right oh my god this is the real thing
so now
so who knows man that's a good point
according to these two high-level
government officials the canadian and
israeli one the aliens are the ones that
are specifically
stopping nuclear armageddon that's
according to again
uh the former head of the israeli space
program the canadian minister of defense
and uh he's saying that the humans are
not ready for them but the aliens are
here preventing a larger conflict from
expanding
i was watching some crazy thing about
orangutans fishing and stuff
you know okay like we're like we're
we're we're more technologically
advanced than they are watching them do
these things like if there could come to
a certain point where we see animals
fighting such a way that we would stop
them
we would be like man this is crazy if
imagine if we were watching you know
it's a thousand years in the future and
we're flying around with teleport packs
and jet packs and then the orangutans
now have nukes
yeah we'd probably stop them you know i
mean we'd be like dude you're gonna blow
everything up chill what are you doing
to advance so the aliens will come back
and you're saying like
what i'm saying is it makes sense that
aliens would stop us from blowing
ourselves up
because we'd be screwing everything up
you know there's very there's a
relatively small amount of planets that
sustain life and are in this
position assuming that they were here
which is a grand assumption i don't
think that they're that's nothing to do
what i just said i said you're saying it
would make sense
would stop wouldn't it make sense that
there is an advanced species here
that okay so anyway my point which what
you're saying has nothing to do with
with my point is that it makes sense for
human beings
to stop less advanced races from blowing
themselves up with bombs
like if you saw a bunch of orangutans
playing with dynamite you'd probably be
like whoa we got to stop though that's
crazy
and you'd probably stop them by any
means necessary because
you got a bunch of you know chimps and
monkeys playing with explosives you
would stop
sometimes but when monkeys hunt
themselves in the woods you don't
yeah because they're not playing with
dynamite and tnt if you think if they
were
like here's the video of the ship with
the ak-47 you ever see that one
the first cgi yeah yeah like if you saw
like a like an orangutan or a chimp pick
up an ar or something you'd be like
stop me and take it from it so that that
that idea
is interesting it makes sense that a
sufficiently advanced
species or or creature would stop
a uh less developed from plane with
crazy explosives i always think like
though
like what why do you think and i ask you
i'll
ask all of you guys why do we think that
the
assumption is that they are if they are
to exist they're more technologically
advanced than us
well but no no but it's all insanity
it's that if any
uh alien species is advanced enough to
come here
then they will be more advanced than us
yeah okay to just such an extreme degree
that a lot of people need to understand
a couple things
like do you can you communicate with an
ant
not really i mean we can play with the
pheromones and make them walk in lines
and stuff
but you can't exchange meaningful ideas
with them we can kind of understand what
they do and why they do it after being
studied
but it you know one of the things i was
watching this crazy documentary talking
about alien life and the components for
life
and the misconceptions people have about
aliens coming here and walking around
like they wouldn't even survive in our
atmosphere like by all mathematical
calculations about the variety of
elements we know of
they could have to exist in some kind of
weird methane atmosphere or something
but even if they did come here it's like
the the level of advancement
from a species you know able to travel
you know well beyond our understanding
in all likelihood either be
substantially more advanced than we are
okay and that would be like you trying
to explain to an ant how highway works
but do you think like on let's say
other planets and whatnot like that
there are lesser advanced beings
definitely i think the obvious like i
think obviously you look at the oceans
of earth
humans are incredibly lucky when it
comes to creating computers and cameras
like if if we look at dolphins man
they're smart right
but they don't have thumbs so they can't
do anything not only that imagine if
dolphins had arms
how are they going to start a fire to
actually separate elements
and create wires and components they
can't do it underwater
so even dolphins octopuses you know they
got they can manipulate stuff they got
you know
but they can't do anything because
they're underwater i guess theoretically
they're like a lava vent and like you
know hold something close to try and
separate the iron out of the rock or
something like that
but we get fire we melt down you know a
rock you know we can separate the
elements and then we can slowly from
there start doing crazy things
i guess there's probably different
chemical reactions that could have
happened underwater
but there's probably planets with water
on it where you've got intelligent
beings
that just live underwater can't do
anything can't build a spaceship and
can't leave
there's actually what is it titan triton
what's the name of the moon
of uh triton i think is that center of
jupiter
jupiter saturn is titan isn't it titan
yeah there's like the one one of these
moons they think
could actually have liquid water because
the gravitational pull
of the the planet i don't know if it
said under jupiter is like causing it to
stretch back and forth which creates
friction which then
creates liquid water and there's they
say there could be life because where
there's liquid water there tends to be
life
but even if it was intelligent what's
going to do break through the crust and
then fly in outer space it wouldn't be
able to do it yeah so it's just there
right so there's probably a lot of
intelligent alien life that doesn't have
the ability to create tools and
you know do anything like that there's a
lot of probabilities here but there's
there's one constant the government lies
that's the moral of the story that is
government lies and with that we'll go
to super chat yes
so if you haven't already smash that
like button and subscribe to the
notification bell and we're going to
read what y'all have to say right now
and uh here actually i got i i i like to
go back to the earlier make sure i get
everybody but here's a really good super
chat he's
daniel yiri says what religion and
economic model will the aliens follow
what if they're like the ferengi and
they're like hardcore capitalists
you guys ever watched star trek next
generation yeah the
man they did really really great uh
writing with philosophy and the
consequence of technological advancement
for those that aren't familiar the
ferengi are aliens
that bought their way into interstellar
travel
whereas most of the species developed it
through science they were
like merchants who met an alien species
that had warp drive and said will buy it
off you
enterprise baby yeah raise the living
standards huh yeah
yeah i love how the life calls it space
communism it's literally yeah it's not
it's literally not that
people own i was i got an argument about
it and they were like
you know no one wants for anything and i
was like dude people have prime real
estate on the beach
yeah there's like they actually show
scenes where people have houses on the
on the on the waterfront in san
francisco like is that just you won it
in the lottery
no people of merit get it yeah anyway i
digress
let's see daniel j coraca says divided
we fall
if as a nation we don't come back
together we will fall
i mean yes if the country breaks apart
then it falls because it literally broke
apart
but i think individual states could
thrive absolutely
i mean we we accept this idea that
states are way
smaller than uh or countries way smaller
than the u.s can thrive
so why couldn't individual states thrive
so i'm nervous that we're being made
useful idiots
that when we talk about because i agree
that if we if we become divided we're
it's over and it when we talk about the
left and the right
i think that that idea is being seeded
into us
from it's insidious i think that it's
china the chinese communist party using
the internet to make us
get more clicks and likes when we use
those phrases because the diversity the
divert you know
it but people like drama and so they're
drawn to this like
easy to visualize uh paradigm
but i think that it's it's so dangerous
like mao used rightists
as his primary focus of who he went
after in the chinese
cultural revolution they were called
rightists he was talking about people on
the right and he used that
to rally the country to violence so
i'm i don't want to use those phrases
anymore
yeah i would say right off hand that it
is just a useful like kind of shorthand
to keep track of who's who
and we do have that useful spectrum all
right let's see
let's read some more of these super
chats joel says taxation is theft and
listen to backwards
oh yeah appreciate the love appreciate
that dan saw f says tim tannerite is
really easy to make
uh it takes some ice packs and some
aluminum powder and and
you can bind on amazon for less than 40
doll hairs
so what what is that do you guys know
what that is tanner um things that go
boom
oh that's awesome i don't know if you
want to just be sharing all that
it's good to know if youtube allows
someone a super chat that they ban a
whole bunch of words
yeah you don't know a lot of that thor
oh says dim fool please be in dc on the
six america needs you now more than ever
i know you're a mild toast fence hitter
but this is not about left versus right
about we the people we need you
well i don't i mean look if we go down
to dc and we do a show we interview
people who are there and like you know
they'll speak and then they'll come up
to our hotel or whatever and we'll talk
to them
like that can be more effective than
being further away i think the worst
case scenarios will be close enough to
dc to get like a post
interview with some prominent people but
uh if there's a bunch of combination of
factors the internet's got to work we
got to have
the system set up and tested and then
there's security issues which are very
serious
i'm for it so we'll see what happens i'm
hearing
i i don't even know if i should say this
but i should probably say it as a
warning i'm hearing people are going
armed
and the problem is you can't bring guns
into dc but i've i've i've seen posts on
the internet where people are talking
about they don't care
because if 10 million people show up
they're like what that's bad man that's
that's that's when things get crazy i
got mixed feelings about it
i got negative feelings yeah i'm
starting to like questions i mean i'm
gonna do this
well what's whether we should do being
there of going there and making a
physical presence is it just causing
more stress than
i'm not going there being able to do
anything political i'm going there to do
a show
talk to people who are there and ask
them why they're doing it yeah being to
report being able to report on the
ground and see exactly what's happening
away from the spin away from the
editorializing is is key and
important so that that to me why it's
important to go trump
has put out multiple tweets be there
i'll see you there
it's going to be wild and then people
are talking about bringing tents
and and and you know look at occupy
non-volatile disobedience i think is
great if everybody just
you know opened their business or
whatever then we would all just carry on
everything would be fine
but there are a lot of people like i
said they're getting desperate they got
nothing left to lose and that's when it
gets scary
so i don't know what's gonna happen man
but i'm hearing i'm hearing scary stuff
that's why i said security is a very
serious issue
you know it might not be a good idea to
go down there for everybody else who
wants to protest i can't look you have
your first amendment rights to go in
protest
but when i'm hearing a lot of stuff
antifa is going to get down there it's
going to get spicy whatever
it gets worrying man all right let's see
jonathan westcott says hey tim black
votes matter is running ads here in
georgia saying they'll be running
raffles for people who show up to vote
straight up admitting it now because
they think no one will call them out
man that's crazy blackmagic says
government is just a social construct
for when a group of people wish to band
together to perform immoral actions
while justifying those actions as
morally good changed my mind
what's the smallest form of government
tribal government
the non-existent the family no yeah the
family problem yeah i would say
yeah that's a good point probably the
individual and
uh no the individual isn't the
government you can just act on your own
but when you have a group of people who
agree on certain terms and someone's in
charge maybe the family
is the smallest form of possible
government families not a bad thing
they're a certain their government is
not like you can't just say government
is bad as a blanket term
what we have in the united states we got
a serious problem yeah too much federal
government i think
yes i mean even local governments are
are crooked
it's like it's hard to scale up properly
corruption just becomes a part of the
system
so i don't know how you solve for that
problem but like
look a tribal you know a group of
hippies on a farm
probably got a form of government that
works just fine you know they're they're
they're they're they have rules
if you violate the rules there's some
kind of punishment you're off the farm
you you're leaving you can't work you
can't live here anymore you know oh
exile
but it gets really difficult when you
can't go anywhere like the united states
is controlled entirely by the federal
government
so it's like if you break one law in one
place there's no
like you get locked in a box and so it's
i think exile is actually preferable to
imprisonment
but you can't do it because people have
nowhere to go did you see spain as
putting people on lists i know this is a
bit of oh if they don't wear masks
tangent yeah or if they don't get the
vaccine
yeah yeah they don't get the vaccine all
right let's see sterling jennings says
when any one
youtuber right-leaning thought leader
has asked if they would run for officer
at a movement
they always say no but i would support
someone doing it how is anything going
to get done if the
if the people who have influence defer
to others that's a really good point
uh because you know i wouldn't want to
be in office
awful yeah you luke i would hate myself
that's a politician
you look at these democrats they want
power and they'll take it
and you look at republicans too but the
listen the republicans aren't arguing
behalf of what republ what the voters
actually want
that's just a fact well you never want
to give power to someone who's hungry
for it you always want to give it to
someone that doesn't want it
yeah like i would love to to take it and
then
make the system so that when we're gone
they don't need us anymore well the
problem is i don't think i know what's
better for
for someone else i can't make that
determination and this is why i don't
want to be a ruler
over someone you can be a good ruler
because of that well
that's the conundrum how can you be a
ruler without being a ruler
is just by being an example that's why
i've been preaching and talking about
decentralization and personal
responsibility if we have enough
individuals that are responsible for
each other
we won't need government uh to interact
and inject itself when it's not needed
so that's that to me is the key and that
to me is a lot better than me becoming
your overlord
telling you what to do yes all right
nuke the ice cap says
what i do enjoy about the obvious
overreach of authority left and right
are looking at it looking at each other
from a different angle
yeah we want the divorce but these
politicians are rightly worried
the thing they fear the most is staring
them in the face
interesting just in moments as i wasn't
big into politics until my games comics
shows and movies became politicized
but in some ways i'm glad it happened or
else i beat another consumer
by the way tim it's pronounced bookmen
oh okay i winced when you read my name
when you when you read my chat yesterday
hi ian luke and liz be safe what up
bookman
bookman rye chaser says eric i'm worried
about the future of the entertainment
industry
i'm currently in film school and when we
pitch our film ideas everyone only talks
about how diverse and political their
film will be
oh my god man i know man it's like
for those of you guys who aren't like
comic book guys
it's it's rough right now like not just
in the but you see it happening in the
shows it's over emphasis of diversity so
you have this tokenization of all these
characters
classically white characters they want a
black version they want a
uh a gender-neutral version but it's
even worse in the books like we're
getting gender-neutral
neutral flash uh yes that's about to be
a thing
uh yes gender neutral flash is about to
be uh about to be a thing
um all sorts of does he flash his gender
i mean
why are they doing that well it's they
they are trying to appeal to people that
don't buy books
right it's these writers are cocky i
think y'all for those of y'all that
follow me on twitter you see me go back
and forth with these guys these guys are
narcissistic and they're co
and they're they're not even in the
business anymore of trying to sell books
or try to make something for a consumer
that was the difference between comic
books now even the ones that they say
were political it's that they were maxed
it was it was balanced and that it was
it was maxed
enough um to where it wasn't overtly
political like only when it was like
going at hitler and stuff like captain
america
right the most politicized right but if
people forget like when
people always talk about hitler right
but forget what captain
america when he started befriending up
nazis he was being obnoxious but before
that he was beating up communists he
used to be called
he used to be called the commie smasher
people forget all
all about that but no that's it was way
more balanced whereas to now people are
writing books
uh doing shows with the they're trying
to lecture the audience right it's about
trying to make sure that you agree with
them
socially so they gotta tell their story
that comes
second right the actual story it doesn't
even have to make sense for them it's
about
what kind of social spin can we put uh
on this can
we focus on racial matters can we focus
on uh
uh so other social matters and and try
to beat you over the head with that as
opposed to making something
that not only appeals to that market but
can appeal to
uh even a wider demographic of people
because
why like my character like my favorite
comic book character as an adult is
batman
i couldn't be further from batman
batman's white and he's rich
i am neither of us but i love him right
it was the ways that
there's attributes and traits that he
has like flash was my favorite character
growing up
the track athlete yeah so that was why
why connect my mother
gave me i was one of the first books
that i read back in the 90s flash book
you ever see uh static shock yes that
was diversity done right
yeah like there's an authentic new yeah
original character and
i don't know any comic book fan that's
like they don't want that what they
don't want is to a black version of this
character that i always know we want
originality so why we like luke cage
this is why we like
uh uh static which is why we like storm
bishop we like these characters
because they're original right that's
what we want originality but they're in
the interest of
recycling hand-me-downs that's exactly
what it is yep
that's what always makes me like isn't
that more offensive absolutely so
instead of saying we're going to write
original
compelling stories for a larger audience
they're like we'll just give you the old
ones we don't use anymore yep that's it
you know we'll just recycle them or just
say
they have the same symbol suit and
everything now the guy just is
all of a sudden a homosexual i i do i
did like into the spider verse
miles morales well my thing about i hate
miles by the way oh no i hate miles i
hate miles i hate him in the books i
hate him
he's just like and that i come from a
different perspective right because
i'm a book reader and miles morales and
he's been around
for a while now he's just a re-skinned
peter parker there's absolutely nothing
from his character we've seen
over the long years of peter parker
being young
being uh uh we've we've seen all of that
from him there's little quirky kind of
comments and what he
all of that stuff is what we've seen out
of that what i more so appreciate is
when they try to make
a more so uh newer character dc creates
naomi or silencer or something like that
original black character or something
like that's
what i value i'm not necessarily in the
interest of taking a historically
white male character and saying we're
just
racist but now they're making those what
was that what was that door of the
explorer superhero
you know that one yeah yeah that marvel
did i think was marvel that did it
fast the gender neutral non-binary
brother and sister whatever
oh snowflake and uh yeah safe space safe
space those are the new mutants right
yeah yeah yeah
warriors and the warriors explorer yeah
like
it was a fat latina chick with a
backpack that has like all this space in
it to pull out random stuff like
literally it was dora it's like the
weirdest thing ever
and they end up not putting that out
thank god
they ended up not putting that that was
so bad to where they were like
they were like okay guys so the new
so you're talking about all those
original new warriors kind of were being
put to the they were there in the
background but it was about these new
characters safe space and
and all these weird weird guys could
create like barriers or whatever
it was one of the worst that's like one
of the worst examples yeah the worst
yeah that was that's terrible
you're a super group of them we need i
think i think uh you know if you look
back at the creation of a lot of the
comics and superheroes
these ideas were original the hulk
absolutely if he gets angry
there's nothing like it before and
that's why that's why people were so
attracted to but now everything's
recycled
yep you know rob leaffield started to do
no no offense rob if you're listening
i thought cable i loved cable yeah
man he was a trash character he didn't
do anything he was a cybernetic he had
he had mental powers like travel through
time
oh apparently he could travel through
time technology they could do that he
had a cybernetic arm
and then that whole rob leaffield would
like recycle like the every group had a
wolf man in it and then they made
brigade for image comics and it was like
every group had like a guy like this
a woman you know um a wolf man a big guy
in the background
yeah we're like like we need some
original superpowers
it's like everything everything feels
generic yeah and it's not like
everything there's a lot of creative
people there are a lot of original comic
book
guys that have kind of deviated from uh
uh
former dc con i have him on my show all
the time from the guys that were
writers of dc and marvel that are
creating the original characters
uh and that's what i think we need and
the world's right right now for it right
now i think more than ever
before and maybe not so much but right
now they are so bad for guys those that
don't keep up with books when i say
they're
like comic books are the worst that they
have ever been
like like when i talk about content-wise
they are the worst that they have ever
bought for both mainstream comics
and dc and marvel they don't sell um and
there's a reason why they don't sell
they're insulting their fans they're
insulting the people that are long-time
readers for these again it's about
lecturing uh the the audience is more so
what they're doing what about manga
though do you read manga no
everybody keeps telling me like that's
where it's at it's actually in some
cases starting to sell more even america
in america
more than what i haven't kept up with
any
uh recent manga for the most part but i
read all of naruto
naruto and shippiden uh and death note
there's some and there's a bunch of
other stuff obviously bleach those those
are kind of uh
you know obvious but that was that was a
long time ago i was reading all those
they were just better stories yeah like
long they don't worry about that and
it's
interesting right they can write
original female characters right that
don't have to be rehashed versions of a
male character they do that so well you
see that in anime um as well so
that's why i can't this whole world all
the ideas have been done and i'm like
have you read watched an anime but yeah
but their powers are unique
unique exactly like how weird was it i
don't i don't you've not seen any
animations like that i've watched anime
you watch you watch an hour or two yes
it was the weirdest thing watching
sasuke have hands
out of his back yeah it's like the
frozen aren't familiar it's like it's
it's one of it's a ninja
and then he gets his power and like
hands and fingers but it's the weirdest
thing ever but i'm like at least it's
original man yeah no that's what comics
in the u.s have become generic
yeah it's the same rehash and this is
why i can't let them make it because you
do see examples of that manga
anime where the japanese are able to
make
original characters original concepts
that we have never seen before that just
knock it out the party one punch man yes
yes amazing
yes there's another one it's like it's
they're new they're like these are
things that have come out within the
last decade right it's not coming out
here
yeah exactly and then you also have my
hero
attack on titan yeah another one like
all these uh yeah like
all these newer contacts these are
things that have happened within like
recent
recent uh recent years and they knock it
out the park it's because they know what
they're doing and they're writing
stories
for their consumers uh uh that will
appeal to them whereas to america is dr
west is
or more so like you know my hero
academia
is about superheroes yeah and i'm like
it's really interesting to see
an anime about superheroes and they're
doing superheroes better
than america's dancing what do you think
would you think we'd be the mecca
of that but it's not like the talent
isn't the sea man yeah that's what we'll
go bro
yes every time you know what i'd like to
see we were conceptualize this with
desmond meeks and philip wainwright
couple of my friends while we were
talking about
stories based on a piece of technology
like a piece of advanced technology and
it follows the tech
like the the gun or whatever and it
keeps getting regular people will carry
it and you'll follow their story while
they have it and when they get killed
or whatever they lose it you you follow
the tech to the next
person and so maybe there could be an
entire genre of
comics where there are no superhumans
but there's just super tech
are you going to write a comic about the
adventures of super male vitality yeah
yeah we'll start with
super male vitality you can get it
infowars.com but now
it's like michael malloy i left it here
and now it's a joke i'm about to edit it
actually
and people are gonna start buying it
like crazy and alex is going to make so
much money because we're
we're making fun of it the genre is
called space punk
okay that's the real thing though i
don't know if it's been invented yet has
it
yeah that's philip wainwright's idea i
believe yeah and
if you're working on it phil sorry that
i that i loaded it but uh
yeah let's all right let's make some
comics let's read some more super chats
razgriz says proud wyomingite here they
can try and ban guns here in 2012 we
were looking at buying an aircraft
carrier
and making it a felony for federal
agents to enforce gun control we will do
it again
i mean yeah well why don't they pass
that law sounds great it's my kind of
party
all right let's see augustine arrive
says damn it forgot you were live
streaming same time
i wa i was lol as if it was any
consolation for anyone here in texas
they say everything is closed down but
the reality is everything is still open
and nobody gives a hoot
so happy i left camifornia yeah i don't
know if taxes is the right call because
too many people are moving to texas well
yeah but they're going this is what i
say about texas is
they're going to don't worry too much
just like the whole eye of texas is
going to turn blue the reason i
and obviously it ended up being a big
dude they're going to the places that
are already blew it first of all
it was actually not that long ago where
texas was
dealing with uh you know we had blue
senators democrat center that was not a
thing that happened not it was not that
long ago let's say that but they're
posting up in
austin dallas houston san antonio those
spots are already blue
so my do i don't want them coming here
and running everything into the ground
if they're at minimum posting up like in
austin that doesn't gain them anything
because they're in austin like that's
already blue
it's when they go everywhere else that
is the problem michael holder says the
problem with the freedom society versus
dominatrix society
is that the control freaks desire to
control never stops at their own borders
china it would only be a matter of time
before the authoritarians would start
oppressing the free staters but that's
what's happening right and but that's
the that's the thing and that's why a
lot of people are scared of like
secession
there is like secession isn't anti
defense
it's not it's not anti working together
right
a community or this concept of of of
uh militias that's not what it's about
so just because we say
you can't rule over us does not mean
that okay if we go to war we won't have
each other's back or something
something like that that already happens
right now like we we we have these
these sort of agreements with other now
some of them are crooked
but you get this idea that okay like we
we like
what it is that you do to to some extent
so if said country tries to come take us
over
we got each other's back that can still
happen it's just like we're just saying
like you don't get to rule over but
think about it this way we have an
alliance we have nato that's what i'm
saying
like you know so and and france doesn't
dictate what we do in new york yeah
exactly it's the same concept yeah
i mean we could still have mutual
defense and i think people forget that
the people who
usually want to be left alone are
usually the people who are
armed and are more able to defend
themselves
than the small people who like to be
dominated and love domination
the united states of canada and jesus
land that's the meme
i could be um convinced but i'm very
hesitant about this idea of a peaceful
divorce i
think that if if we tried to secede one
the
that the american government would
invade immediately like they did in the
civil war
uh they caught the war of american
aggression right whatever
but i think that was most likely to
happen when it happened but now with the
advancement of technology
um and how you know the the
weaponry is so it's advanced enough for
us to be able to hold our own and i
don't believe like we're just going to
get overtaken
we saw what they what what happened with
the rice farmers the other there's
a billion guns in the states alone
my other worry would be that like the
chinese government would invade the
seceded union and then the united states
would
also invade to to defend it and it would
become a proxy war and then it would be
leveled
well the red states have their own
military bases and national guard
well so what what are you is saying is
that the chinese government would
influence the dominatrix side
and i would say that already has
happened no no no i'm saying that they
would invade the secession it's the
freedom side
they're not but they're not engaging in
third generation that's what i was just
about to say
china china would just take control of
the dominatrix society because of their
their interests
so they would fund the secession they
would they would arm the secession
you'd get this for an influence on the
uh right that's what we did in vietnam
they're doing it
china absolutely and if there was
influencing american politics and a
bunch of negatives oh that would be the
best thing in the world for china if the
americans split apart
i mean depending on what you want from
the world
it might be chinese communist party
become the most powerful force on the
world
on earth well they already are going to
do that
under abiding presidency exactly they're
they're they're doing well they're doing
beaching drills for taiwan you think joe
biden is going to do anything about that
joe biden's main advisors are talking
about how a bigger growing china is
great for the global economy
and they're investing in that country
and they're and they're enforcing
laws walmart is investing into wuhan
as we're speaking right now how would we
defend against it but that's why i'm
saying if you break up
i mean you like do you i don't think
people understand the
the vast amounts of of gun laws and at
the federal level that exists right now
yeah right
i think if if that was broken up you'd
see more people wanting not only to
from a creation standpoint but wanting
to invest in that sort of weaponry that
would have them ready to rock
right like i'm talking what you consider
more
these automatic weapons and stuff that
they consider machine guns
um all tanks which you know depending on
where yeah you kind of can get that
sort of stuff but we'd be more inclined
to invest
in that certainly if they got the hell
out of the way
i think the biggest myth is that we need
them to
to to protect us when we as individuals
could invest in ourselves but that's why
they want the dependency
so we get to thinking like that that's
exactly what they want it's like well
you need us
because if we get away from you then oh
everything's gonna fall apart and i just
simply disagree i do not agree
that that is the inevitable thing i just
don't they're dominatrixes that don't
know a safe word
yeah impulse 818 says hi tim how come
you haven't mentioned
at all the war criminals that trump
pardoned last week
yep hasn't come up but it came up now so
i think it was bad i think it was wrong
but
you know obama pardoned a bunch of crazy
people and blew people up so i think for
me it's like
i didn't spend four years wearing a maga
hat waving a trump flag i was
you know fairly critical and i think the
media was just insane on trump so put me
in this position where it's like dude i
can
say it's bad that trump did these things
with missile strikes in syria
criticized him for it john bolton we
bring up all the time the commando raids
in yemen the death of it was an
eight-year-old american girl that was
killed
uh in a raid uh ordered by trump these
bad things all happened
so i was related to anwar al-awaki right
right exactly
so yeah the sister was was killed by
trump has done
a ton of bad stuff and over the past
couple of years it's been getting better
trump pardons people and he does a bunch
of a big wave of pardons and
i mean you know i think it's bad who
would he pardon
people right yeah he pardoned water
mercenaries that were responsible for an
estimated 17 deaths of
innocent civilians they were found
guilty and were serving a pretty severe
sentence
and this is kind of us when do they go
to prison
i don't know the exact details of
exactly let's pull that up if we can and
look up the details here because i think
that's
pretty important here but to me this
symbolically is a big slap in the face
of julian assange of of wikileaks of
of chelsea manning and all the other
individuals who want
accountability for edward snowden for
who want accountability
for the war crimes that the united
states has sometimes committed now
again we have to see this through you
know
the rule of law and a court found these
people guilty of
of ending 17 innocent people's lives and
that's that's a big severe crime that's
a big severe
implication that trump is saying it's
a-okay for him
which is it was a little daunting it was
2007. so this was under bush
yeah yeah these people are nasty dudes
man and there's a lot of really messed
up stuff america should not be over
there
yeah well he's also friends with the
head of you know black foreign you know
for the former black water
something else yeah eric prince so um it
doesn't
it doesn't make him look good you know
in my opinion scott says tim i've heard
you give the best summary of the
non-aggression principle of anyone who
rejects its universal moral applications
why do you reject it
how do i reject it do you believe in the
non-aggression principle
define the non-aggression principle you
defined it better than me according to
that super chat that's why i'm saying i
don't understand how i rejected so let
me hear what you have to say and i'll
tell you what i think
well not aggression principle is just a
basic principle that you
believe that ideas shouldn't be forced
onto people there shouldn't be any
aggression forcing someone to do
something that they don't want to do
that there shouldn't be force
an extortion used uh to push a certain
entity right
being initiatory that being the most
important point right so there's a
couple ways to look at it
if we're talking about violence and harm
whether it or or or
force against another person be it
physical or coercive well yeah
don't don't pick a fight with somebody
don't mess with it with other people
let live and let live if you want to
talk about a government system and
you've got a big city like new york
that's been around for hundreds of years
well now we've got a very much more
difficult and complicated question
yeah but that's and that's always been
the more i think the misunderstanding of
the nap is that it's like this sort of
end-all right and that's not what it is
what it does is
it's just fundamentally understanding
what the principle is that we want to
uphold
and that is that it is absolutely wrong
to initiate
uh a force upon someone else so if
you're not being threatened if you're
not having
someone hit on you and i think most
people can't agree with that
the straw man comes in and they say well
what about this instance in this
instance and i'm like yeah i get that
there's a questions or that we can come
up with as to the nap never pretended to
be like
uh the end-all or that if it exists and
nobody's going to commit no it's in fact
you know we look up to robert murphy's
of the world we talk about privatized
law for that reason
nothing is perfect but you have a
reduction of harm under the nap
principle which pretty much asserts the
rights of individuals
not to get aggressed upon a lot of
people are commenting saying the
blackwater guys were convicted for
political convenience based on weak and
inconsistent evidence
that was from amenti jm says obama made
villains out of the blackwater guards
for political purposes
the media didn't start lying in 2016. am
says they did not kill 17
the government made all that crap up and
paid iraqis to lie because obama wanted
out of iraq and had a vendetta against
blackwater i don't know though he didn't
get us out of iraq
yeah he kept the soldiers there
and i i mean you're making a claim there
i mean i will say that i will
legitimately look at it
but i haven't seen any evidence but
again i'm not perfect i'm not always
right if you think i'm wrong on that
issue please send me some evidence so i
could look at it
you could message me on twitter luke we
are change and then i would love to see
any evidence you guys have
and of course i will change my opinion
based upon that regarding non-aggression
what do you guys think about
forcing aggression on people that litter
well that's why we want uh private
ownership right so if that person owns
that particular
land or groups of people right if they
um homestead it which would be the way
that they owned it or if it was a
transfer of ownership
by way of purchasing it or being the
land being given
um yeah like that there's a case to be
made that that is
that is absolute because you're
violating the private property that's
what aggression
is right that's essentially breaking it
down is a violation of the you know the
private property right
be it in land be it in uh owner
self-ownership so i
you punch me in the face that's an act
of aggression but the same can be said
for
a contract violation um or something
or or something like that i think
aggression in the libertarian sense
which is a good question by the way
in a libertarian sense is also like very
misunderstood no
luke you had something well again if
you're living in a society where
everyone is responsible for themselves
you're not going to want to go around
causing troubles for people right
a lot of people don't want trouble a lot
of people just want to be left alone a
lot of people just want to work a lot of
people just want to live their lives and
and be happy so if there are i mean
nothing's perfect
nothing again is a hundred percent
libertarianism doesn't
pretend that it is yeah definitely by
itself
it makes me think of family life and how
kids won't clean their room unless
they're forced to
like i i would never clean my room
unless my parents were like you're gonna
clean your room it's dangerous you're
gonna trip over trash trying to get out
if there's a fire
clean your room and in society people
will just throw banana peels on the
ground if there's no
if there's no recourse well that's the
thing though if so
there is there is absolutely a case to
be made if
i have private property i own said thing
and you just go in there and start
dumping stuff on it what about city
streets
city streets i mean that's the same
thing those should be probably owned so
if that but
whoever whoever wants to make whoever
provided it to service
if they want to shut off access what if
they did
what and what and then someone else
should build a role
but it would well i mean that would take
time what if yes it would what if they
could
but what work but what's the incentive
for them to do that like i know we're
talking about what's indication what if
they you angered them in a deal that
and they just shut off the run hold on i
gotta make i gotta make a ref call
what if the police block a street and
say shove off
that happens they do that all the time
now you can't go here if you don't have
a minute
cops in new york created something
called the frozen zone it happens now it
was just made up and they used it again
you can't come on the street it's frozen
you're like what does that mean i just
want to know what the inside i know a
lot of people talk about
my roads but i'm like they and they go
to these extremes and i'm like what's
the incentive there
like it's always what if this happens
but hold on human beings don't operate
like we use
it's a purposeful action use vanderbilt
as an example because he on the
railroads going into new york city and
he decided he didn't like the way they
were treating him so he cut off access
to the to new york city when he
starved the city out and they realized
we can't let a guy
own the railroad anymore that is i don't
have that recollection of
the 1850s of the of the railroad system
uh
there's anti-trust laws for a reason
because people are doing stuff like that
but they're not used especially with big
attacks they're they're well you know
it's not even
hold on let's stop let's let's backtrack
let's talk about the railroads though
was the state involved in in and
all right so how much how much of the
world is i'm assuming that you're
familiar with the story
how much of the railroads did that man
on he owned as far as i know he owned
the rail
he owned all of the buildings all right
he he owned all of the all of the rurals
do you are you familiar with like
because again i'm and i'm not asking it
sarcastically i genuinely want to know
what was the scenario in which had him
had where that one individual controlled
all of the railroads
i would have to i i want to know that
because i have a hard time believing
that one person on the railroad
uh and there was no state involvement
yeah i have absolutely i i don't believe
that that was the case i i just cannot
believe that because that has virtually
never happened
anywhere else didn't happen with bill
which is the closest thing that we can
point to in america uh when we talk
about actual
monopolization and it didn't happen with
the bill monopoly
so i don't understand why when we talk
about these instances
i want to know where that camp get came
from i'm very curious
well another thing we have to realize is
humans have an initiative to be
cooperative with each other
they have an initiative to work with
each other and to be
in a way where they are able to work
problems
out with each other without you know of
course using force because when you use
force everyone loses so bingo i see
a huge reduction of harm it's not going
to be perfect some people are going to
get hurt
like it won't happen you can act like
you're a communist and everything's
going to be solved overnight
but it's surely going to be way better
than the system that we
and it goes back to what we were talking
about earlier even if i don't or anybody
in this room doesn't have the answer
doesn't mean someone else won't yeah
here's some info
um vanderbilt was a shipping guy he got
made his fortune in shipping
and then it's in the 1850s turns
attention to the railroad bought up so
much stock in new york and harlem
railroad by 1863
he owned the line he later acquired the
hudson river railroad in the new york
central railroad and consolidated them
in 1869.
okay so like i said i want to know more
about that particular process i want to
know more
about what was what more so it allowed
him how was that one person
allowed to do that like not out what he
did more so
i don't think anti-trust laws existed
until after rockefeller uh standard oil
but i don't think that first of all that
didn't protect none of that prevents
monopolization anyway again when we talk
about
the monopolies that have existed
throughout america uh the ones that you
can point to
every single one of them um have have
happened by way of the state being
involved um and benefiting the person
who wanted to own all of this it's not
like oh i went here
you uh you had something that i wanted
to purchase voluntarily so i bought it
it's no what happened with the bill
monopoly it was well hold on
here here's this uh service that we're
gonna provide you want to
compete with us no you can't because we
worked with the government and the state
has made it illegal for anybody else to
build it like that has happened
and this is why when we talk about
moving or rather transitioning from the
system it is that we have right now
you can't look at it through the lens of
the what if
bezos what if this person this person
that got
extremely wealthy off of government
contracts
we can't look at it through that lens
because that's not
what we're we're not living that
vanderbilt didn't get rich out of the
government he was a shipping
private enterprise guy well i'm not
talking about him how he he
he got his money and even with shipping
i want to know to the extent
what and again i'm not familiar with it
i don't know so i'm not going to pretend
like i have the answer
to that but i just have a very hard time
believing that
one person without any sort of
competition because
i can't find any other example where
that is existed without any sort of
competition or rather more so
without the assistance of the state was
able to just up and say
you know what uh i i now own everything
it is that exists because
that doesn't make that i can't process
that but if it's true
okay but i have a hard time believing
that this is why i need to
i'm gonna have to look at the receipt to
myself on that because i'm not gonna
pretend like i have the answer
i just have a hard time believing that
that was the case where someone just
voluntarily without was able to
monopolize an entire industry
i i have a hard time a good documentary
called the men who built america that's
worth checking out
yeah uh well you know if you look at any
super rich powerful individual today
they got that way from manipulating the
current system that we're under
and using a form of socialism for the
super rich
while screw off everyone else just do
whatever you can to stay afloat
while of course uh the super rich gets
tax breaks incentives and grants and
handouts
uh while of course the majority of
people are screwed over before
government
before really we had government it was
all private people would go
form their own cities and they would be
like the god of theirs john astor built
astoria new york he was the god of
astoria and there was no oversight they
were the
they became the when did that when i
have never heard of that existence i
mean rome was built after a guy named
romulus that like that didn't happen
with even with slavery
when we talk about the country being
built by people that were through
private enterprise like that didn't
happen then
so i don't underst i i'm having a hard
time believing that this gap
happened in which okay all of these
people got rich
no state no not using any sort of form
of statism and were able to
be the soul the sole producer of that
again that didn't even happen with
slavery when you talk about slave codes
fresh off the boat where that was a
status institution so i just have a hard
time
uh more so more so believing that i get
the fear
i get the fear but every every for the
most part of these examples you can
always point to
well this person was able to leverage
the state local government or something
like that
to be able to either price uh you know
we got to talk about minimum wage laws
and how that is
existed and how union workers would
would utilize this to price certain
people out of the market
this is stuff that has existed over the
course of american
of america's history so i i don't
believe that there was ever a gap
where the state wasn't if there was a
true monopoly because it's one thing to
be a
uber or uber rich i'm not like anti-rich
and i'm not suggesting that there are
people
that got rich by way of voluntary
exchange but if they become the sole
producer
generally that means that they made it
illegal for someone else to produce they
made it illegal for that person to be
able
uh to make that particular product ip
laws is uh is another example and how
that has
how that has been utilized to manipulate
manipulate that where we see some
one company owns the the patent for for
this and no matter if someone wants to
make that particular let's say drug or
something like that
for cheaper they can't they can't right
or so i'm just using that as
a kind of wild example but that's an
example of how that sort of stuff
exists so i'm gonna have to look at the
receipts on that
all right let's see uh bub savvy says
tim you cleared up the railroad question
with hotep how long until rockefeller
would have to answer to the people and
collaborate to prevent vandalism
yeah that's a good point like no like
that's why we talk about incentive like
i know the the people's brains
definitely nowadays we see how evil the
government is
it immediately defaults to what is the
absolute worst that can happen so
someone comes up with some uh
complicated scenario what if
this happened and then that happened and
that happened and i have to ask the
question like
why was that knowing that human beings
act
purposeful action that's why we call
economics the study of human action
right
not number messing around with numbers
and stuff but why
did that person act in the way that they
act so what incentive does a person that
oh i own the one one road right uh that
can get to and fro and that person
decides okay i don't want anybody else
on it what incentive does he have to do
that
he's not going to be able to get good
transport but that's it right
ideology but who's to say or just a
general hatred or emotion
that can be a thing but that but that's
what i'm saying like how
likely is it that someone when we talk
we talk about trucking and stuff like
that
and uh the concept of transportation why
on earth would someone
that definitely if the idea let's say if
it's greed or something like that
why would they derail that particular
let's say source of income
just for the sake of well like if i
hated somebody if i owned all the roads
in this
neighborhood which would be nearly
impossible for you to do if somebody
owned all the roads in this neighborhood
because they bought them all from
someone else i
again that that is uh but it's possible
under the thing you're saying no it's
not
are you saying the government hold on no
i'm saying that when free people act and
come
compete with each other it is highly
unlikely for you to do that unless you
are prevented but it's possible
no no not highly unlikely yes possible
yes but possible hell it's possible that
i could slip down the we talk about 99
survival rate you can't criticize or or
fear let's say this concept existing
just because it might be impossible
hold on a second consolidation for 20
minutes and i'm going to finish this
statement hold on a second
consolidation of wealth is a common
tactic so if i owned all the roads in
the neighborhood where you lived listen
to me
and your wife bothered me and i wanted
to screw you
i could that's very dangerous okay all
right
first of all that again for in order to
do that it will be nearly impossible for
you to enforce that by the way nearly it
would be not if it's private security
yeah
so enforce one person on a road and
that's another thing when we talk about
the privatization of roads
how about you you explain to me how
you're going to enforce that i
hired a hundred guys how are you going
to hire 100 guys to do what
to block the road for you specifically
for me for just it's just
me and this happens and this happened
when i was in l.a i went to the staples
but just for you no but i'm saying i
understand that people
travel people have warrants and stuff
and stuff like that but
you know right now people there are
people that have like warrants
let's say for their arrest right now
that go out there and travel
just relatively freely yes right now and
so how likely is it and this is this is
my frustration with that question
because
completely nonsensical hypothetically no
it's not there there are business chains
that have people's pictures you're
banned for life
there's oh absolutely absolutely but
that's a casino that's not a road
you see what i mean you're talking about
a means of travel where hundreds and
hundreds really thousands of people may
travel
yes because how it how difficult is it
for you to enforce that
the road versus versus you being in
someone probably normally easily two
guys with a checkpoint and guns
what what you all the checkpoints are
you're gonna have a person at every
single checkpoint checking every single
we're talking about going to and from
but that's talking about hold on man he
said
one road and to screw with you that's
not what he said no first of all he said
that if he if he wanted to screw me over
he would have to own all of the roads so
first and foremost he's operating under
a nonsensical example okay let's use
it's a high let's see so
you take my road and you get to the city
in an hour otherwise you got to go
around it takes 10 hours
okay i own again wow what guys i put
your photo but i don't like you all
right so again
why are we operating yet again on
another nonsensical
nonsensical because how likely is it in
a free society that only one road would
get one place
to where ten you had to go around for a
turn of ten a one hour trip
to a ten church it's called the bridges
in south jersey that is
again entirely monopolized by way of the
government right now so we're talking
about
exactly exactly so we're not but we're
not talking about that right now
we're not talking about um the an
example
that exists right now and then trying to
put what it is that i advocate
on that particular example that's why i
keep saying that you're operating
on a straw man you're operating you're
trying to look through it through the
lens of what exists right now
i'm not advocating what exists right now
we have nothing close to what it is that
i ex
huh twitter yes what about it twitter
monopolize political discourse
how did they monopolize political
discourse we're talking about politics
right now
on youtube where are we talking about
the roads so so
there there's uh uh absolutely i'm not
and
i'm not saying i'm not say again
no no i don't consider paypal monopoly
even though they control 80
of internet internet financial exchange
yes i would not consider it but i'm not
advocating i'm not saying that there's
there's not a problem there that's not
what it is
if you're if you're banned you can't
operate on on basically and you can't
make money
and how do we get to that point because
paypal is the first and best dressed
first and best dress
first in first first and best dress okay
first
best dressed what it means is paypal was
one of the first platforms to allow
interchange
between various internet companies okay
because everyone used it right it was
the easiest way for people to function
right
we now have some competition one company
stripe but stripe has a lot of the same
policies as paypal okay you get banned
from paypal
you're you're not making money on the
internet anymore
so what's the point look i'm asking you
for the point like what what do you mean
like what it was paypal has banned
conservatives and right-wing individuals
yeah
i understand and destroyed their lives i
understand that i understand that
but i'm trying to understand what the
point is here so
what are we what ian was saying is that
for
seemingly arbitrary or ideological
reasons okay people who control
massive can have massive control yeah
here we go operating on
under the premise that they are that
that is a thing why i tell is the thing
i
understand that pay pal we're talking
about transportation and roads okay
so with that being said how likely of a
scenario in a completely
free society why is it that the default
is that one person controls the road
because that doesn't mean
that that doesn't even happen in in the
country right now vanderbilt no it
doesn't matter
there are private bridges and roads all
the time that's what i'm saying though
that's exactly the point i think what
eric is trying to say here
to symbol to make this kind of simple is
that there's a lot of bad people out
there
but for for the bad people to use
institutions and systems to to enforce
their bad ideas
is a lot more harmful than if there was
a decentralization
and they didn't have those larger
institutions to force or hurt people and
why that is that that is silly because
the government is the one institution
that can monopolize things and they
monopolized all of these things and for
someone to say that that is the solution
i don't come i don't even understand
government make sure that no
one person owns all the roads and again
they do well they actually do that they
the government the state themselves i
mean that's why that's what they do with
the railroads for instance well no what
i'm saying
that's how the transportation system
works in this country right now
well so why is it okay for the state to
monopolize it but you think
you fear so much that the that there is
uh let's say some private individual
that would do it why is it preferable
that uh because we own the state no we
don't well no we don't have the
government
that's not how that's not how it works
you may not know no no that's no
legitimacy
have you ever seen a private security
guard punch a cop in the face
no they do it all the time you got
high-powered six-figure security guards
who will punch a cop in the face you can
watch the videos online
a cop will walk up and there'll be a
high profile yes i know i get that well
people beef on the cops oh hell i went
to the point is
if you've got at least the police have
some accountability
mobs don't who mobs don't
who are mobs who who who are large gangs
accountable to
i'm afraid if you live in the south side
of chicago and gangbanger kills your
brother or friend who are you going to
call what are you going to do about it
oh you're going to go to the gang leader
and be like
well i want some some you know
reconciliation they do it now and
there's very
barely any reclaimation there's a lot of
murders that go look at what happens in
chicago anyway and look at what hap
right that's the point yeah you have no
way to hold any of these games
accountable except
exactly no no no even if you go to the
police you don't get any accountability
in the south side of chicago
hold on hold on you guys are speaking in
absolute terms that is not correct
okay i'll tell you this if there is a
one percent chance that i go to the cops
and say i'm mad that guy killed someone
i know
there's a one percent chance something
gets resolved it's better than going to
the gang and he's gonna laugh in your
face
or point a gun in your face so why do we
look at it like the state itself isn't a
gang
i didn't say it wasn't i said at least
so so you you just
you just want a bigger gang then right
you don't think there's a counter i grew
up banging by the way you don't think
there's accountability among gang
members
oh how do you think we are there is but
not for people outside the gang the
people in my neighborhood
who get killed get nothing but if you're
in the gang and you
and you could commit some fraction they
say we'll take care of it that doesn't
happen
same thing with antifa same thing with
cops that doesn't have but that's what
i'm saying that didn't happen with the
state
it just happens on a grand or bigger
level in the middle east i'll tell you
this
when you have these cops in all these
different circumstances
who who are involved in justified
shootings like an actual incident where
they were being shot at or something and
defending themselves
and they still get fired and they still
get prosecuted yes you got we got so
there is still some some accountability
for the police but accountability
that's not justice if if you said that
they were doing the right thing
and they get punished that's not an
argument
i'm saying the fact exists that there
can be accountability for police and it
happens first of all what are you what
do you think it is that we're advocating
that's what i'm i think we have a big
time confusion here because i'm not
i'm advocating for privatized forms of
uh security and law so i'm not
advocating for a complete freaking
free-for-all you're looking at it as if
where the state is
as it exists at least they're
accountable which i think that is being
that's overstating it but i'm i i would
love more
more so for village i don't know if it
how exactly there's more accountability
g4s or uh nypd like why does that
what what are you asking in that
question like why why are you asking me
that serious question
because we're we're you you know but
what's the point like what
why like why are you asking me that in a
sense so the conversation started with a
discussion about a private road right
and an individual being able to tell you
to go right
but again you're all right so we're
looking at it like all right at least
this exists
here right what i am advocating for
and this this is this going to apply to
you as well is that there is a market
that exists i accept the idea that
there's a bunch of water bottle
companies right a bunch of people that
can create water
um dasani um ozarka
um aquafina um smart so all these sorts
of companies that can do that and they
compete
and they and they compete with each
other right and municipal water
they compete with municipal water too
they what i'm saying is
is that all of these exist for the law
it does not
right now that is completely monopolized
by way of the state what i am advocating
is is that that system in itself
be voluntarily arrived in a sense that
there are competing
firms so i don't want one instance in
which because
it's funny how we we immediately go to
the the the extreme right what if this
so
hold on hold on let me finish let me
finish this you just made a point i
gotta answer it right no no
no no i haven't made the ending point
what you're advocating let's talk about
the end game of that
this whole what if scenario well what if
i or let's say any other any person
wants to become let's say ruler of said
of said land
and utilizes the same state that you
think
is supposed to protect you and then
kills i don't know
one two three six million
people the government itself the state
is
most attributed to we're talking actual
like forms of democrat and killing their
own citizens
you will find more instances of that
which is why it's completely lunatic
let's go back to the lawyer it's
completely hold on hold on i just want
to finish at one point it's complete
lunacy
to act as if what i'm advocating is
something that is extremely crazy
when the ideology that basically you're
advocating for which is
the state is far more responsible far
more examples
of them way back than what it is that
i'm
so what happens if i hire a law
enforcement agency
and uh they arrest you and i'm a i'm a
high paying customer with tons of
contracts with this company
and you're not why is it that i i i i
just don't understand why we keep having
to operate
on a what if where the we go to the most
extreme example how's that extreme
it is it's very extreme because you're
operating under this guise that this
setup was that
okay that's exactly what it is that i
want so it's a what if
i didn't say that that's what i did that
was that you're a competing law
enforcement yeah
no no what i want is competing firms how
that comes to about i have no idea
no way to predict that you don't i can
theorize is it by way of some
sort of insurance no it's not no i'm not
i'm not you you just said no
utopian means personal society i'm not
asking i'm not advocating society
you just said no what else no no i'm
saying what exactly that's the point
because i don't know
you don't know either none of us know if
i knew
if i knew we wouldn't be talking about
it don't work no you know you can add
you can have it you can
theorize that's exactly that's i just
want a system where the labor is
controlled by the people why don't we
just do that
why okay why don't you do it because it
doesn't work comedy
okay yes it fails every single time i
think you should be free to act that out
voluntarily
that's all i'm saying let it fail let it
don't use force
government agents that's awesome
socialist communist society i'm not
operating on utopianism because i'm not
pretending like there won't be an
instance of instance where someone gets
murdered there won't be
answers where someone has a wrongdoing
i'm not stupid enough to advocate that
but it's a silly that's why it's so
silly for
someone to try to pin this like
definitely on the ideology it is that i
advocate
to try to pin this like uber perfect oh
what is uh if this happens what is the
what how does eric july and
libertarianism solve it the whole point
of a market is that i don't know
well when you bring it up you let the
market go idea i want to
brainstorm that idea i'm all about
that's what we're doing right now right
so i will give you the biggest
flaws my issue with that my issue with
that especially with you
what you saying utopianism because
you're pretending like i'm
saying that it's perfect i don't know
hold on i am not under
any sort of you got man handled by
private security was g4s
no where were you build a bird there's a
lot of like security
that have confrontations you ever file a
complaint um
no usually it's the police that arrest
me and harass me more and
make up bullcrap stuff on me yeah yeah i
know yeah right right have you ever
filed a complaint against cops
um i actually did yes yes in new york
city
i was beat up by the cops when i was 16.
and i filed a complaint with the went
with the civilian complaint review board
and after investigating they found no
instance
of anything that happened and it was all
[ __ ] that just absolutely wasted my
time and nothing
ever you ever complain about the private
security that's roughed you up um
i see come on dude you can't private
security i mean what private security
specifically 4s was roughing you up at
some hotel
uh that wasn't g4s that was the private
hotel security and then police officers
came and assaulted me and then arrested
me and put me in a cage
when pl when the security was trying to
manhell to me i pushed them back
i walked away from them and i told them
if they if they agree
on me what's the solution
the solution someone with more don't
know we don't know the answer we don't
know the solution but i think it's
best to strive towards a
decentralization towards a
a society where we are responsible for
ourselves and don't depend on anything i
think the government should control food
no okay do you think they should control
let's say um
with clothing right should they should
they control clothing
okay so why is it that you think that
they are best suited the state
right the government that's essentially
the state the territorial monopoly
why you think that they are best suited
to let's say solve
all of these problems that i guess you
you or maybe you that were we're talking
about it inside
someone's block off the road i'll give
you one example
we have a constitution that guarantees
me certain rights and often those rights
get trampled on
but at least there is a semblance of
accountability i've been through this
system
i've been wrongly arrested on more than
one occasion and i've gotten
my albeit imperfect version of justice
in that
i don't think i should have been
arrested in the first place but i end up
winning now i've also been
manhandled by private security who laugh
in my face and who am i going to call
i'm going to call i'd like to file a
complaint with your company are you a
customer no
then bye well i mean well we certainly
don't have any instances this is why
i don't under i don't understand the
mentioning of that because right now we
don't have like it's competing firms
right now completing firms in what
capacity what do you mean and when i say
competing firms i'm saying when we talk
about
right now the state monopolizes law it
decides what's wrong it decides what we
have
right no we don't no we don't not no we
don't have conflict no the state may not
there is no competition against
let's say the state what they say goes
is ultimately they may
they may who kashmir what about what
what what
you got two different governments
fighting for control but again i
understand that but no we have because
we have federal governments we have
state
state and we have state governments we
have local governments that state that
states competing with
with other states and that's why i would
prefer that they be broken up for that
exact
reason because i prefer them actually
competing with each
competing with each other in a sense
that definitely when it comes to my
mobility and being able to move i would
prefer that
be a thing as opposed to government or
one world government or something like
that yeah so
like cities have different laws stages
different laws counties have lost yes
countries have laws right so you can
freely move to different places with
different laws if you don't like yeah
exactly competition exactly what no no
no no that's why everybody wants
what i want what i want is more of that
this is why i would prefer
decentralization right because why if i
accept that canada is different from
america why can't i accept that texas be
different from
uh the rest of the united states so why
why do we accept exactly that's what i'm
saying that's what i'm advocating i
don't know
as a solution
judiciary in the united states well it
wouldn't be a united states if that was
the case
like if if virginia's got its own laws
and west virginia's got its own laws if
that's a fact then you can choose to
live in one of the other states bingo
this is why i advocate for
decentralization yeah so
the initial conversation we were talking
about is someone owning a road and
deciding to cut you off because they can
yes and that happens yes and oh yeah the
state cuts me off
all the time business licensing and all
the exact same thing no no it's not the
exact same thing because when they get
to do that i actually it's
it's it's more likely that i can fight
against someone else than i can in the
state anyway
there's nothing at this stage if the
state exactly that's the problem yeah we
don't want big i don't want the big
monopoly that's the thing i don't want
that monopolization that's the whole
reason why i advocate what it is that i
advocate so it doesn't make so
when you're talking about competing
firms yes it exists
not in the libertarian sense no i want
more compe i want more
i don't want to move to what's that
state in mexico i don't watch um
uh cheer on chiron aren't you why aren't
you there well excited because i'm here
or or well out of texas i would rather
decentralize that
because i lived there i was from there
that's more so what i want why am i
required by to do you do you tell like
people that i don't know get aggressed
upon to just stop getting aggressed upon
if you live in a bad neighborhood leave
the neighborhood yes that that so that's
what you tell them instead of
i don't know i know i moved away from
where i was where i'm from
but that's not the ultimate solution
that person still did something wrong
to that person at the end of the day
that's wrong right you you'd agree
murder
theft and all those sorts of things rape
those are very bad things and
the last thing i don't tell a woman that
gets raped well you shouldn't have
wore that skirt we don't tell people
that it's totally different no it's not
it's the same argument that you just
made
yes it is yes it is the argument i made
is if you keep going
if you keep going into an alley and
getting robbed stop going in the alley
you just made that same argument yes you
did yes you did you made the same
argument that you're not placing you're
not placing the responsibility if you
listen
yes i know that but that's what i'm
saying when it comes to the wrong doing
choices
yes you have choices so i was telling
somebody to leave a bad neighborhood the
same as blaming them for wearing clothes
and getting raped
why is it not because the reason why no
it's not because you're saying that if
someone said let's say
a female dressed a certain kind of way
and that person and that
you know i don't know someone like the
way that that person looked and that
person committed an act of aggression be
it an assault
rape or or what have you that's the same
exact argument you're the abuser is not
yes it is i'm not the abuser i'm not i'm
like
because we're talking about the state
right if i'm in a bad neighborhood oh it
doesn't have to be a state we're talking
about actual
aggressors if i'm in a bad neighborhood
i understand that yes i'm in a bad
neighborhood is it preferable if i have
the mobility to be able to move
absolutely that doesn't change the fact
that those people that are other being
destructive to their community
aren't bad so the thing that i don't
test but that's why i'm not sick
i don't default to yes it's preferable
if someone is is using aggression upon
you
try to go the other way this turn the
other cheek we say that stuff
all the time or rather defend uh defense
what is all right explain it to me one
more time
i want to get your argument right if
somebody is like here's a dark alley
that i've been robbed in three times
and you're like that's crazy and they go
i'm gonna go walk through it again
wouldn't you be like hey maybe you
shouldn't do that all right
all right i'm gonna try to use let me
let me let's let's try to see if this is
the same analogy
someone know knowingly got let's say
assaulted
we let's go back to the they've been
assaulted several times no
no that's what i have a choice right
someone is sexually assaulted right if
someone is sexually assaulted by the way
of the you know the person was attracted
to them because they wore whatever
whatever thing that they that it is that
they wore if they choose to wear that
of course it's not the same exact thing
that's why i said an analogy tim no
but how is it a different argument
explain it you have an alley yes
where there's crime yes and you keep
going in there yes and you keep getting
all right
that's i'm using the same exact thing
you have a person that's wearing
clothing right
and and they keep they get because they
they they dress in a certain way
men or whatever same people because
they're wearing the same clothes every
time
that's a farewell argument to stop going
around those people and leave the
neighborhood tim i understand that i'm
not saying that that isn't the
preferable thing to do what i'm saying
is i don't blame that person
for wearing those sorts of clothes and i
don't think
when that person is aggressed upon so
when you say
well just move that is that's why i'm
using that exact
example because all you're doing is
telling the woman after she has been
assaulted
because of what she's wearing you tell
her just don't wear it
that's not a realization for
clarification you might not like
clarification
anymore clarification eric said ship
and second uh i i see no one has been
taking the ashwagandha i've been given
out to people i haven't uh
and are there more super chats that
maybe have more input
on this i love the idea that there are
people who live in
cities that are upset that they choose
to live in this city
and they do and they're mad they got to
pay taxes on that city
because i literally walked
away slept in parks got in my car and
just left
and you know what i was broke and i said
whatever it's my choice to choose where
i'm going to be
how is it incumbent upon someone else's
neighborhood to provide for me i'm not
saying
i don't want to leave i certainly
haven't made that argument that it's on
the neighborhood to provide anything for
anybody all i'm saying is is that i
don't blame that person
for being in that situation just because
whether they was raised that way whether
they got family there whether they got
kids
and if someone is being is aggressing
upon them my i don't say
oh well you just leave right no i'm like
oh that aggression is bad
is it preferable considering that that
is the circumstance that you live in
to get the hell out of there absolutely
that's what i did i'm from south dallas
i grew up banking
i grew up claiming blood i get out i
grew up doing all of that stuff and of
course it was preferable
for me to remove myself from that that
doesn't change the fact
that i as a person that grew up doing
that was terrorizing my own community
it has everything to do with what we're
talking about tim because that's what
i'm saying
that that is on the aggressors i was
actually the
the aggressor back then terrorizing my
own community so
i get it i'm not disagreeing with the
idea that if you can
if you have that mobility to be able to
get the hell out
do it but that is not i'm not gonna say
because someone aggressed upon someone
that was living in south dallas living
in chicago or living in a rural part of
la
that they should just up and leave no it
is wrong what their government is doing
it's wrong for what gang members uh in a
certain area or whatever wrongdoing is
happening
let's start argument and put it this way
you have a choice to live in new york
city new york city's got a city
income tax yes okay that's crazy you can
leave
yeah you can there are competing
jurisdictions vying for your resources
yes and that's money and that's why i
want them i agree with you 100 that's
why i want more of them
and we have we have tens of thousands
yeah no i don't know
well we have 50 in terms of the states
i'd i'd love if there were more
you country
because i'm here but you can go there i
can go i can go anywhere i go a lot of
places but i don't i live actually in a
way in a place that i actually like it's
part of
why i would want to break away from the
federal government because the federal
government is the bigger aggressor than
texas
where i'm at so i want them off my back
so i would rather
separate from them than move i don't
know away from
from somewhere else i like where it is
that i have and again this is the
interesting
question there's two different
approaches interesting i think both of
them have merit well it's an interesting
philosophical argument that
i don't want to leave so everyone else
should change even though most people
seem to agree with it
what most people in this country are
totally fine with the weight yeah so why
vote
why voter do any of that thing then
because yeah people disagree they show
it ways
by way of their voting with their dollar
by way of actually voting by way of the
state
they all show that that's they disagree
in some way shape or form that's a
complete non-argument we
everybody everywhere for the most part
is disagreeing with people yes of course
that there are more
let's say non-libertarians to me there's
also more let's say where i'm
living at maybe more red there's more uh
republicans than there are democrats a
complete non-argument of course we
disagree
but the what i'm the point that i'm
trying to make is that i would much
rather the reason why i would i don't i
don't i don't mind secession because it
gets the power
closer to the individual so i i i agree
with the point you're actually making
the argument for me this idea that
well western virginia is different from
from from maryland so i'd rather go
there okay i would want that applied
even more the simple the simple thing
out of all it says
you like living under the rules of the
federal government
no more than you would prefer to leave
that government
no i i like the there's a was another
multitude of different reasons as to why
i live and where i live
what it ultimately boils down to is that
i like where it is that i am
i i love it don't get me wrong um i like
i like the culture i have a i have a lot
a lot of like-minded people that live
around me
who is on my back right now the most is
the federal government that doesn't mean
if
the federal federal government
completely gets out the way that there
isn't a fight to be had it's an easier
fight to be had
to oppose let's say the denton county or
whatever as it is to oppose texas
as likewise it's easier to oppose texas
government than it is to propose the
federal
government so again i agree with that
point it's actually making my point of
why i think that there
uh uh should be more especially if we're
going to come to some sort of
uh peaceful uh concession what it all
comes down to is
you would rather live where you are yes
with everything the problem all the
problems you have with the federal
government yes
than in a freer state like jerome no no
no that's not what i'm saying what i'm
saying is
i like no notice otherwise you'd be
there no no no just getting there you'd
be there oh yes
exactly that's the point i don't want to
be there but you're trying to put you're
trying to put the reason why i want to
be there
on me and i think that's disingenuous
for you to do that
you could rather be in one place than
another yes
absolutely i'd rather be a place than
another i don't want to live there i'm
not familiar with the culture i was not
raised there i don't want to be there
there are a multitude of different
reasons because i don't want to
go somewhere else to complete
non-argument it doesn't mean anything
because what i'm talking about right now
is that in this instance the federal
government is my biggest beef they
tax me the most they uh when it comes to
some of these uh would be social
security and all these sorts of things
that have to come out of my check or
rather they they expect to be paid that
i don't want that so i fight against
that yes there are other reasons why
culturally i don't want to be
be somewhere else so it's not because
it's necessarily just free that's only
one
one aspect yeah i can go to somewhere
that may be quote unquote freer
my family's not there the real problem
is
as civil civilizations scale up
and all land falls under certain
jurisdictions
then there's nowhere for you to go and
what do you do
when most of the people in the country
are fine with the way things are going
you could do it you do you can advocate
for it that's that's exactly and that's
what that's what i do that's why i
i am as vocal as i am about the
philosophy it is that i adopt because i
want to see some sort of change
other people do it in different ways
some people uh want to enact change by
way of voting some people want to enact
change uh
um you know by way of uh you know
community activism
church or or whatever it is they have
their ways of going about it
uh my battle to fight is here that's
where it's at i don't want to bail i
don't want to just leave
my battle was fight it i was raised here
i understand the language i understand
the culture
this is where my battle is and i want to
work towards a free society and i'm far
more useful here
than going somewhere else just up in
berlin just because they're they may be
quote unquote free
it's not about me wanting but you know
to live under this
particular federal government and not
under where somewhere is free no that's
just one
aspect of it the the thing is there's an
endgame that i ultimately would like to
work to
and i want to fight the battle here this
is where i am familiar this is where i
feel
that i'm supposed to be i'm not supposed
to be in wherever the place it is
in mexico i don't know where that said i
don't live there things that are
challenging
i like challenges the start of the
conversation was basically
competing uh judiciary systems i suppose
legislative systems yes
and they exist yeah i know they exist i
never said they didn't exist what i'm
saying more so
is i want more of those to exist and i
want it to be
far more competitive what we have right
now when you look when you consider what
the federal government is
is is that it has monopolized this
entire land and there are rules that we
must follow
half of them don't even make sense
considering the geographical area that
i'm in
that unfortunately they impede on
people's freedom on people's rights and
i don't like that
so i want i would rather dissolve that
and that's one less problem that doesn't
mean that that's the end all that
doesn't mean it stops that'll mean just
because
oh the federal government broke broke up
and now the states are now countries or
or what have you that means the battle
stop no and this is why i always say
that it is a it is a not necessarily a
battle of might it's a battle of wits
i'm not completely oblivious to the fact
that i live somewhere
that most people here aren't
libertarians i'm not completely
oblivious to that i know that this is
why
it's an educational war as much as it is
as much it is
as much as it is i'm all might because
if we this is why i wouldn't side with
antifa type
if we ended the government as is right
now
where have we gotten nowhere all that's
going to happen is
is that a new one is going to form in
this place as long as the people that
are living there
still think the same way it is that they
think and this is why i say it's just as
much educational as it is
i agree that they're the federal
government too integrate
in what we're doing but i also think
that there's importance in regulation
that that the government does utilize
regulation sometimes
yeah to destroy small businesses and
allow amazon and all these other big
box companies to profit and destroy
small businesses
and sometimes it's to keep the roads
free for everyone to use so there's all
i think there is a value to leaving some
sort of federal
or making sure there's florida and
people's drinking water so their teeth
are yeah imagine if the wall
if if the government had a full monopoly
on water
how much crap would be in that water
well as we know luke
the that you're completely wrong because
all they did was put
fluoride in it yeah that made our teeth
clean yes not a fan of the fluoride
guzzlers
i'm super curious what the the super
chats have to say about this
conversation and where they stand
i think maybe we could even do a poll
saying if you agree
with this kind of idea you press one or
you press two
if you disagree jdtn says tim is saying
your situation sucks so leave
eric is saying your situation sucks so
fix it not true
what i'm saying is if you're advocating
for competing
legislative or judicial systems and
there's competition between them
you would like i'll put it this way
let's say there's a bunch of different
burger restaurants
and you're like man i keep going burger
king it gets me sick every time okay go
to wendy's
right you don't or do you stand up and
burger king demand they fix that
absolutely well it's it i mean that's
actually a form of uh
of more of a marketized form of
regulation because what happens if
uh this per this burger king or whatever
did do that and i go
run my big mouth about this is why i'm
against like concepts like the civil
civil rights act and actually there were
examples of that one of the biggest
myths is that well the southern states
all just wanted to be very racist
against people that is factually
incorrect you can look to examples like
plessy versus ferguson where you had
examples like the louisiana boxcar act
and also known as the separate boxcar
act
and there were actually companies that
did not want
to segregate their people that's not
what they wanted to do they didn't want
to segregate them but instead what
happened was and that's why i had a hard
time believing that
the state just up and allowed that uh uh
uh or the state wasn't utilized
to allow that sort of monopolization
that we were mentioning earlier
the state with the separate boxcar act
forced companies to segregate what
colored folk from black folk it was not
a market
the market itself the actual company
which again don't take my word for
anything
go look it up was actually against that
law for
economic reasons it would cost them more
about to spend more money on boxcars
having to try to separate the white folk
from the colored folk so they themselves
in the south
were were against that particular law
and there's instances that for whatever
reason
we don't we don't talk about that let's
have the market decide
press one if you think tim and ian are
correct
press two if you think me and eric are
correct i am let the crowd decide
because my point is if you're advocating
for the ability to choose between
jurisdictions you can do that
i'm not saying you shouldn't try and fix
the place you're living in i'm saying we
made a lot of different arguments and i
think
press press one tim and ian
luke and eric or nine or seven one or
two let the crowd decide i think that's
the most interesting way to
match that key first this conversation
we just got in uh just a whole slew of
super chats there's a whole bunch man
there and they're all
well let me just there's just so many
and let's see let's
scroll down uh tim is right tim is the
best
he has the monopoly of control when it
comes to comments
no it's mixed it is uh some people are
saying that you know
uh and i'll only read this one ensuring
small gang tribal warfare is almost
inevitable
from anarchism there must be some type
of social construct agreed upon to work
people equals a disparaging term eric
you're being defensive af breathe man
lol jk you're all right
this is me like this is slight work like
we're we're individuals that talk about
these guys
it's fun all the time this is slidework
i hate that's gas textbook gaslight man
you relax
they said they said lol jk it's like
come on relax
when you talk about smaller conflicts
i'd rather have smaller conflicts than
bigger conflicts and someone like joe
biden with his k
with his fingers on the nuclear trigger
right now i'd rather have that
so my personal choice in the you know
tube amps rule says ian i've never seen
you conclude your point more gentlemanly
than you did
today thank you sir very nice
the dead man says ian should look up the
story of thorn from destiny
the gun is the focal point of the story
is concerning multiple guardians
yeah i played destiny and yes yes let's
check it out
let's see blai uh blaze 88 says tim's
logic equals move somewhere less free
if you don't think you are free enough
here that's that's absolutely incorrect
i'm saying first of all i'm not leaving
this country so i love the constitution
constitution needs to be enforced
so i agree we got we got to fix these
problems the federal government has been
amassing too much power these the the
shift away from local government
into federal government has caused
problems for everybody across the
country
so i think we all agree on that there's
a reason why if people have the choice
to choose if people have the choice
between jurisdictions
it's funny how they keep choosing to
come here because you know it's the best
in the world isn't it
gotta fix a lot of the problems though
all right let's see we've gone way over
so let's just read a couple more
ed's world says anarchy ends in pay to
win
dylan keller says if you guys end the
stream without spinning the male
vitality i'm gonna flip
okay i'm gonna try and get it back on it
fell off the metal it fell down
all right all right all right dane
phillips says just found out about eric
from the show last night been watching
his stuff all day
great stuff tim and co very cool now
that we've we've gone an hour and 15
minutes over oh
yeah that's fun i like it i like it but
you guys need to take ashwagandha
that's another topic no you need to take
doesn't isn't isn't the male vitality i
don't think we i think we need less of
male vitality from infiltrators
male vitality spin that male vitality
but it was an interesting debate it was
fun you know and i know but i think the
comment section will let us know i think
it's it's fair to say
we all agree that the state is the only
source of moral good in the world
and that the ability of individuals to
freely trade their goods is is amoral
and wrong
and and that the only true uh utopia
will emerge once we
take away all of the rights of free
trade and communize
the entire planet under an authoritarian
uh one world government for the greater
well-being
for equality
yeah decentralization and competition
uh with a good referee in my opinion so
i'm in favor of a mixed economy
and the us shifts a little bit back left
and left and right but it's fairly in
the middle when it comes to
uh economic freedom it's far from a free
market capitalism
and a lot of regulation ends up becoming
just gum in the gears of the machine
making it
messed up it's used as a weapon to hurt
small businesses by big business and
that's what it's historically done
minimum wage a lot of these things that
people advocate right now were
absolutely
used to do just that to to hurt
competitors
you know i think the problem is with the
with the health care system because i
hear the people on the left saying
single payer simplify everything
and then i hear the right saying free
market show the prices and i'm like
you know those are both actually fine
arguments there's a lot of pitfalls you
could probably find in some of them for
different reasons based on moral
arguments
but what we have right now is like they
took some of just different parts and
just
mashed it all together and our
healthcare system isn't capitalist
or socialist it's just a weird match of
corporate profit that doesn't really
you know but a better way to put it is a
bunch of people getting rich off the
backs of a bunch of other people through
the power of the state
that's not a free market and that's not
a socialist system at all
it's a broken mash of garbage so
there you go socialism for the super
rich corporations
oligarchy is that what it is it's just
people who don't contribute extracting
values in the power of the state
that's what we have right now it's not
it's not they say it's the capitalist no
it's not
if it was capitalist you'd have people
competing with each other you know you
know how much
an aspirin cost you don't even know the
price you go to the hospital and you're
like i
you know i went to the hospital several
years ago i had a kidney stone they
didn't give me a list of the price of
the breakdown they just gave me a bill
for 25 000
a day later after after a day in the
hospital and i called them and said what
is this
i was like 25 grand i was in the
hospital for a day and they were like
well you know just give us insurance i
said i don't have insurance
because it was the it was the week
between my when i left advice i went to
fusion
and they said oh oh let me send you the
the corrected bill uh-huh
four thousand yep how does that make
sense sixteen grand
from an insurance what was that that
would have been twenty one thousand
dollars
twenty five was a total bill so so what
does that mean
six hundred percent yeah uh markup or
something they didn't write on the
prices either i was like i know this is
because the system is broken right now
it doesn't make sense
so that they're they're that's that's
the real problem it's it's it's
it's not we're not we're not you can't
mash these things together
and then just have like a frankenstein
of a system it doesn't make sense i'll
leave it at that huh
all right eric thanks for hanging out
that's awesome that was fun yeah it was
good yeah
we went long we definitely should yeah
so uh
i don't know we we'll probably do
something fun and extend for new year's
eve maybe we'll go we'll go live all the
way through are you
are you hanging out i'm gonna be here
until till thursday so
morning of yeah wanna go yeah so you'll
be so you'll be here for new year's eve
the day yes a little bit a little bit
but i'm leaving that day
that's the day that i'm leaving all
right well you know we're gonna have a
lot of fun but uh you wanna shout out
your channel anything like that oh yeah
young group of five nine that's the
channel if you wanna holla at me of
course
at uh eric d july everywhere else
twitter you name it man and again i
appreciate you
officially appreciate you having me on
like this is this is the substantive
conversations that we need to have
a lot of people i i always love when
people come like this is the best
episode ever
yeah no that's whenever whenever
whenever we're yelling at each other
so good friends do man that's what i'm
saying like if y'all thought that i'm
gonna like punch
like tim in the face or something like
that like or ian like oh yeah
he was on an argument no that's not we
could have boxing matches yeah
yeah yeah i mean it would be
volunteering of course but no no
no it's all good we'll play an airsoft
game and we'll film it and then eric's
like
luke what's your channel my youtube
channel is we are change and you can
find me
under luke we are change on instagram
twitter venmo and
i also have t-shirts that like the one
that i'm wearing today and yesterday
that you could buy on teesprings we are
changed
i got some really good ideas for
clothing we're gonna make soon let's do
it
yeah shout out if you're a graphic i
think i have a few graphic designers
already it's gonna be fun
it's not gonna be political well well my
pictures my short story helps me to be
free and independent and it's been huge
and i thank you guys so much for
purchasing it because it keeps me up and
running and keeps me away from
you know doing anything else so thank
you i appreciate you yeah
ian i hear that you have a twitter or
something i do it's at ian crossland you
can follow me all over the internet in
fact my youtube channel i just
uploaded a video today talking about
some ideas about fixing our government
our financial system and our internet
uh bill of rights that you can watch on
my youtube channel at ian crossland
i think everybody here like we have in
common is like libertarian
in a certain degree like varying degrees
of libertarian is what like
but then there's like cooperative versus
competitive you know like certain
arguments
but uh yeah i don't think it's it's not
doesn't strike me as a utopian answer
but
it seems like the most sensible path
towards like a next generation of
united states one world communist
government or something simple like that
and of course you can follow uh you can
follow us our apache lives
and i really do like engaging with
libertarians much more than
authoritarians because libertarians tend
to think out what they
think and authoritarians do not it's
easy you can follow me on twitter
instagram parlor
tim cast check out my other channels
youtube.comcast and youtube.com
and also make sure you check out the
show on itunes spotify and all podcast
platforms leave us a good review it
really really does help
man the show's been doing really good on
podcast platforms and that's where it
kind of
that's where like the the big i don't
know it matters
the podcast is legit stuff but uh you
can check us out monday through friday
live at 8 pm here on youtube.com forward
slash tim cast irl
smash that like button hit the
notification bell subscribe
we will be back tomorrow at 8 pm thanks
so much for hanging out and we will see
you all then
bye guys
you